[Musique]
Pierre connais ça. Bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle Syerview.
Comment ça va ?
Tout fait ça va.
Qu'est-ce qu'on va aborder aujourd'hui ?
Qui qui êtes-vous d'ailleurs ?
Moi, je suis un fonctionnaire instable,
c'est-à-dire j'ai fait une grande partie
de ma vie professionnelle dans
l'administration.
J'ai commencé par enseigner. Ensuite,
j'ai été juge. Après, j'ai travaillé au
ministère de la défense. Après, j'ai
travaillé à Matignon. Après, je suis
revenu au ministère de la défense et
j'ai terminé les 10 dernières années de
ma vie professionnelle à diriger une
société d'intelligence économique. J'ai
un cycle d'emmerdement d'à peu près de 5
ans. C'est tous les 5 ans, j'ai besoin
de changer de métier.
Donc maintenant, je suis dans une
situation très stable puisque je suis
retraité et donc je peux me permettre
non seulement de parler librement de ce
que j'ai pratiqué dans ma vie et puis en
plus de la situation internationale.
Voilà à peu près le descriptif.
Votre vision de la de la situation
internationale, ça s'arrange, ça
s'arrange pas ? Est-ce que les les
puissances dialoguent de mieux en mieux
? Est-ce qu'il y a du de la
radicalisation tant sur les politiques
que sur les religieux ? Comment ça se
passe ?
Il y a beaucoup de choses qui sont en
train d'évoluer
et dont je pense que les mécanismes de
régulation de la vie internationale
n'ont pas pris en compteement.
La première chose, je crois, c'est que
toutes les crises qu'on a connu après 91
sont des crises qui ont des
particularités qu'on a pas pu détecter
dès le début. C'est-à-dire qu'elles sont
devenues plus longues. D'abord, elles
ont commencé comme crise interne,
Yougoslavie, Syrie et cetera. Elles se
sont internationalisées souvent par
participation des pays périphériques
comme par exemple au Congo et puis
ensuite elle s'internationalise avec
intervention de ce qu'on appelle les
puissances de la sur la planète. Bon,
donc elles sont devenues plus longues,
elles sont devenues plus complexes. Le
cas de la Syrie est justement le cas le
plus intéressant puisque là, il y a
quatre guerres en une et chacun mène la
sienne en se demandant ce que les autres
viennent faire là-dedans. Euh et
très souvent, il y a des acteurs qui
sont des acteurs non étatiques et face
auxquels la légitimité d'une action
internationale, j'entends les cinq pays
permanents du conseil de Sari n'ont pas
les moyens intellectuels et physiques ni
militaires de d'intervenir.
Il y avait un chef chef afghan qui
disait une phrase que je trouve
particulièrement euh significatif de
l'évolution des crises. Il disait "On
peut pas acheter un chef de guerre
afghan mais on peut le louer." Ce qui
est l'explication même de la logique de
la guerre en Afghanistan. C'est-à-dire
le type qui un matin est doit se
reconstituer à partir de l'état d'un
gouvernement qu'il faut reconstituer et
cetera. En fait, on n'y arrive pas. On y
est arrivé pour la Yugoslavie à cause de
la proximité puis pas à cause d'une
espèce de proximité de culture. Mais on
voit bien que sur la Syrie, on a
aujourd'hui des multiples acteurs qui
ont tous des intérêts différents. Que
nous on voudrait sauver les Curdes mais
que les Turc voudraient surtout pas. Que
les Russes voudraient sauver Assad mais
nous on voudrait pas. Que aujourd'hui on
se bat contre Daesh mais on accuse
l'Iran. Enfin, je veux dire, ça
ressemble fort à un film des des Mars
Browsers où on donne la des claques, on
se donne des claques mutuellement puis
c'est finalement le plus faible qui
ramasse la la mise à la fin, quoi. Donc
voilà, c'est un peu ça la description.
Pour ce qui concerne les membres
permanents du conseil de sécurité,
il faut quand même se rappeler que ce
sont les vainqueurs de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale qu'ils avaient eux-mêmes
contribué à déclencher quand même. Et
donc le reconnaître encore aujourd'hui,
si vous voulez, une espèce de compétence
pour réguler la vie internationale est
une espèce de souvenir sur lequel on
devrait prendre un peu de distance,
surtout quand on dit la responsabilité
historique et cetera. Notre
responsabilité historique, si on le
regarde sur la Syrie, par exemple, ça a
été de faire le plan pico avec les
anglais. On peut pas dire que ce soit un
franc succès qui légitimerait en tout
cas qu'on intervienne aujourd'hui.
Et la dernière caractéristique des
crises, bah c'est celle que la France a
connu. C'est-à-dire quand on se mêle
d'une crise dans laquelle notre comment
dire légitimité à intervenir n'est pas
évidente. Il est certain qu'on
intervient plus facilement sur le monde
arabe que par exemple sur le
en Asie du Sud-Est ou ou dans d'autres
endroits de la planète où il y a des
problèmes. Le Congo, c'est la crise la
plus meurtrière depuis la fin de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale et c'est pas
pour ça qu'on s'est précipité.
Et donc qui a des effets en retour sous
la forme d'acte terroriste devrait être
une caractéristique qu'on qu'on prend en
compte. On n'est pas les premiers à
l'avoir connu. Les anglais et les
espagnols l'ont connu après leur
intervention en Irak sur la guerre
illégitime, illégale qu' décliné qu'
avait dessiné George Bouchement. Nous,
on fait comme si c'était ces gens-là qui
nous déclaraient la guerre alors que
c'est nous qui leur déclarons la guerre.
Donc c'est une caractéristique
évidemment importante des crises
aujourd'hui et et il faut reconnaître
que la France a une caractéristique,
c'est que c'est le pays qui a la plus
grosse communauté musulmane, la plus
grosse communauté juive, la plus grosse
communauté chinoise et la plus grosse
communauté arménienne de l'ensemble des
pays de l'Union européenne. Donc quand
j'entends dire que notre modèle
d'intégration fonctionne pas, j'ai
quelques hésitations sur ce constat. On
a un problème avec une partie de la
communauté musulmane. Voilà, c'est ça le
truc. Et donc tout ça, si vous voulez
sont des adéquations de la diplomatie et
de la politique française que je
souhaiterais voir apparaître demain en
se disant est-ce qu'on a besoin comme
avec les deux précédents présidentes de
faire du suivisme voire de
l'anticipation par rapport aux lignes
américaines ? J'en suis pas convaincu.
Sur la Syrie, qu'est-ce qu'on fait la
bague ? Est-ce qu'on on fait pas une
grossière erreur de de d'aller taper
avec l'alliance anglaise et américaine ?
Je sais pas parce que en fait euh moi je
prendrai la situation sur la chambre du
proche Orient.
Euh la phrase la caractéristique qui me
frappe le plus aujourd'hui, c'est qu'il
y a une guerre sunichite au Pakistan, en
Afghanistan, en Syrie, en Irak, au
Yémen, à Bahrain et même au Nigéria.
Bon, or une guerre sun cheit, je suis
pas sûr que notre intervention de
croisé, si vous voulez entre entre
guillemets soit obligatoirement le
meilleur des postures pour intervenir
dans une guerre de religion. Ça c'est la
première chose pour ce qui concerne la
Syrie d'homme même que pour ce qui
concerne l'Irak. Moi je suis toujours
frappé du fait que ce on se croit nous
légitime à régler une question qui
concerne d'abord les pays de la région.
Si le régime Assad a eu tant de
difficultés à rétablir la situation,
c'est parce qu'il y avait des groupes
islamistes qui étaient financés par les
pays du golf. Et donc vouloir dire il
faut la tête d'assade sans se demander
qui était en face posture qui était qui
était celle de Fabius et de Hollande et
quand même quelque chose sur lequel
encore une fois on aurait dû
s'interroger avant. On a une
caractéristique c'est qu'on militarise
avant de réfléchir. C'est-à-dire que au
lieu de se demander quelle est la
dynamique de la crise et si on a les
moyens politiques d'aboutir à une
solution, on commence par militariser en
disant "Oui mais ça ça va calmer tout le
monde." Or on a bien vu un certain
nombre d'endroits dans lesquels ça ne ça
ne calmait pas. bien au contraire et que
au contraire ça mettait parfois nos
soldats dans des situations difficiles.
Donc avec la caractéristique du retour
sud de flamme que représente le
terrorisme, on a aujourd'hui quelque
chose qui est assez surprenant.
C'est-à-dire que notre intervention en
Syrie et en Irak se traduit par 240
morts et 900 blessés dans les rues de
Paris et aucun soldat tué sur place.
Donc il y a peut-être une espèce de
petite adéquation qu'il faudrait refaire
dans la tête de nos dirigeants.
Est-ce que Est-ce que c'est le le fait
qu'on qu'on passe par des proxy comme
l'Arabie Saoudite ?
Est-ce que le chien va se retourner et
mordre la main de son maître plus
profondément ? Quand on voit des des
pseudo coup d'état en ce moment en
Arabie Saoudite avec des tirs près du
palais royal. Est-ce que
quelle est votre opinion là-dessus ? Bah
moi mon sentiment est que on a longtemps
évité la question de l'Arabie Saoudite.
L'Arabie Saoudite est depuis une
trentaine d'années à peu près notre
meilleur client en matière d'équipement
de défense.
Quand on voit avec Hariri euh
ça c'est un autre aspect cher ami parce
que les les affaires en Arabie Saoudite
n'ont pas la même logique si vous voulez
que chez nous.
Pour une raison assez simple, c'est que
en Arabie Saoudite il y a pas de
distinction entre le budget de l'État et
le budget de la monarchie. Donc quand il
manque de l'argent dans le budget de
l'État, c'est le roi qui met et quand il
y en a en trop, ben la famille pressère
se sert. Donc on était sur un système où
effectivement il y avait une espèce de
on peut même pas l'appeler corruption
puisqueencore une fois la corruption ça
signifie qu'il y a une une espèce de
régularité comptable du budget de
l'État. Là c'était de la rémunération
d'intermédiation. C'est un système qui
fonctionne sur le sponsoring.
C'està-dire pour faire des des affaires
là-bas, il faut avoir un partenaire
local qui de toute façon prend 51 % du
capital. Donc même s'il met rien, il est
propriétaire de 51 % du capital de
n'importe quel investissement étranger.
Bon, ça donne de mauvaises habitudes ce
genre de chos. Bon et le coût
extraordinaire qu'a fait Mohamed Ben
Salman quand il les a tous invité au
Ritz à Riad en leur disant "Venez donc,
on va faire une conférence sur l'avenir
du pays." et puis qui les a ensuite
enfermé en leur enlevant leur téléphone.
C'estàd la précaution était le système
était bien conçu. Et qui donc il leur a
tordu le bras jusqu'à ce qu'il parle. Ça
a été plus que d'ailleurs leur tordre le
bras. Il y en a un qui est mort, on sait
pas trop, dans des conditions un peu
particulières. Donc il y en a un qui est
sorti au bout de 2 jours, il a donné un
milliard de dollars. C'est quand même la
chambre d'hôtel la plus chère de la
planète he 500 millions de dollars la
nuit. Et puis ensuite les autres sont
passés, ils ont raqué et cetera. Donc on
sait pas s'il a recueilli 60 milliards
ou 100 milliards à peu près avec cette
opération qui est quand même la plus
grosse opération anticorruption jamais
réalisée dans la planète. Quand même, on
a jamais réussi à être aussi efficace
que lui.
Donc cette opération a deux fois un
avantage et un inconvénient. L'avantage,
c'est qu'évidemment vis-à-vis de la
classe moyenne qui tout à coup on
présente la facture de l'électricité, de
l'eau, de la TVA et cetera, c'est
l'impression que tout le monde va
contribuer, même forcer contraint. Mais
évidemment, d'un autre côté, c'est cette
base là qui assure la solidité du
pouvoir des Saoudes. Bon, donc se fâcher
avec les princes et la famille royale et
en tout cas toute cette bourgeoisie qui
tourne autour des affaires en Arabie
Saoudite, ça peut entraîner de la du
mécontentement. il a quand même mis
aussi il a quand même fait cracher aussi
le pardon la famille des sultans qui
sont ceux qui tenaient toutes les
affaires d'armement par exemple. Bon ça
fait 30 ans que nous on avait le même
interlocuteur comme au ministère de la
défense et donc c'était l'homme qui
lui-même et ses et ses ses proches enfin
ses parents prenaient les commissions
sur tous les budgets de sur tous les
achats d'armement.
Or il leur a tordu le bras pour qu'il
rende l'argent. Il l'a fait pareil avec
le patron de la garde nationale et la
garde nationale c'est sont les
prétoriens du régime, c'est-à-dire ceux
qui sont là pour assurer la survie du
régime. Bon, c'est quasiment une armée
mais qui a une une armée qui a vocation
à réprimer n'importe quelle
manifestation d'opposition.
Donc, il a quand même fragilisé tout le
système sur lequel il repose. Ce qu'il
n'a pas encore touché aujourd'hui, c'est
le véritable le noyau religieux. Il les
touche par la périphérie. C'està-dire
qu'il ouvre un cinéma, il autorise les
femmes à conduire. autoriser les femmes
à conditrice,
je sais pas comment les femmes pour
apprendre à conduire. Peut-être que le
moniteur s'assera derrière si vous
voulez, j'en sais rien mais en tout cas
ça pose un petit problème technique.
Donc elles pourront conduire à partir de
juin, elles peuvent assister au match de
foot, ce qui est quand même une
extraordinaire innovation. Je sais pas
si elles vont y aller, mais en tout cas
elles ont le droit. et puis des petits
trucs comme ça. Mais le noyau dur, c'est
quand même le fait que la hiérarchie
religieuse tient quand même l'école, les
bibliothèques, les universités, la
culture, enfin tout ça. Donc on est si
vous voulez encore dans un combat de la
périphérie. Il est pas encore il s'est
pas encore attaqué à ce qui est
véritablement l'autre pilier du système
saoudien. Il y a la dynastie des
Saoudes, mais il y a la dynastie des
Halcher, c'est-à-dire la dynastie les
descendants d'Abd Wahab qui sont
créatifs en matière de conneries puisque
ils ont ils en sortent régulièrement. Il
y avait celui qui disait que la terre
était plate. C'était le précédent ça.
C'était le le grand moufti antérie qui
était dans les années 90 et lui il
disait il était devenu aveugle. Donc il
disait quand on lui a fait remarquer que
c'était un peu étonnant qu'il dise que
la terre était plate, il a dit oui mais
quand j'y voyais elle paraissait plate.
C'est quand même astuce. Il y a l'autre
qui a interdit qui a dit que Mickey
Maous était donc un un agent satanique
puisque le prophète avait demandé
d'exterminer toutes les souris. Donc il
y a une créativité qui fait que la vie
saoudienne est quand même très amusante
à vivre.
l'Arabie Saoudite, la Syrie, est-ce que
l'Arabie Saoudite a un grand intérêt à
faire basculer le régime de Bachar
Elassad pour des questions de pipe ?
Est-ce que c'est une légende d'urine ?
Au début, au début oui. Parce que
la grande les deux grandes tendances
politiques du monde arabe, ça a été
comment dire le le panarabisme avec la
volonté de faire une société socialiste,
laïque et cetera. que représentait
Nasser, que représentait Assad, que
représente
Kad
Kadfi et puis Boudian en Algérie
et l'autre grande tendance. Alors Nasser
était un type qui avait plusieurs fois
dit euh critiquait fortement les
monarchies du golf et il disait en
particulier les Arabes feraient mieux de
s'occuper des monarchies du golf que de
s'occuper d'Israël.
Donc il y a eu dès le départ une
animosité très forte entre les
monarchies du golfe et cette mouvance si
tu veux qui était beaucoup plus
moderniste.
Euh simplement les monarchies du golf en
avaient besoin parce que ils étaient pas
question qu'elle fasse la guerre
elle-même hein. Par exemple l'Arabie
Saoudite n'a jamais participé à une
guerre contre Israël alors que la
frontière dans le Wolf d'Akaba est à peu
près une trentaine de kilomètres entre
le sud entre Hélate et la frontière
saoudienne. Ils ont envoyé une brigade
en 67 mais elle est arrivée trop juste
parce que la guerre n'a duré que 6
jours. Donc le temps qu'elle arrive la
guerre était finie. Donc, ce sont des
monarchies qui se sont sentis surtout
très préoccupés de cette poussée de
cette modernité proprement arabe. Et en
fait, dès le début, il y a eu cette
opposition interne au monde arabe
qui s'est traduit en particulier par le
fait que quand Nasser a persécuté les
frères musulmans, ils se sont tous
réfugés en Arabie Saoudite qui était un
pays qui avait besoin de de cadre. Bon
et donc cette opposition là s'est
structurée autour de on en discutait
entre soi mais comme ils av comme les
monarchie du Golf avait toujours besoin
que l'Irak les défend contre l'Iran, que
le les autres fassent la guerre contre
Israël, ça n'est pas apparu
fondamentalement. Par contre à partir de
67, c'estàd quand la guerre des 6 jours
démontre la faiblesse de toutes ces
armées de de ces pays modernistes où il
y avait Syrie, Irak et cetera et cetera.
À ce moment-là, les Saoudiens reprennent
la main et ils reprennent la main
surtout après 73 ou alors là, à ce
moment-là, disposant d'une masse
d'argent gigantesque, ils vont faire de
la diplomatie religieuse, ce que je
raconte dans mon bouquin. Et là, ça va
couler à flot. C'est-à-dire qu'à partir
de ce moment-là, le salafisme tel qu'ils
vont répondre va se tourner contre le
régime de Nasser et contre ses régimes
arabes en particulier contre Assad. Et
puis il va évidemment se propager un peu
partout sur la planète, y compris chez
nous,
sans que à jamais à aucun moment on ne
considère que c'était une dangérosité
pour nous.
Est-ce que cette forme rigoriste de de
l'islam est en train de leur échapper
avec les mouvements terroristes ?
Ben, c'est une forme radicale de l'islam
qui effectivement leur échappe. Elle
aura échappé en plusieurs circonstances.
L'année charnière pour le régime, c'est
79. 79, il se passe trois événements qui
vont mettre en difficulté la monarchie
saoudienne.
Euh en février, euh il y a la révolution
iranienne. La révolution iranienne, ça
veut dire que les chiites reprennent la
main sur tout ce qui est islam
révolutionnaire. Ils reprennent le
discours anti-israélien et cetera et
puis évidemment de dénonciation des
monarchies du golf.
Et Roménie a une idée particulièrement
urtiquante pour les pays du Golf,
notamment pour l'Arabie Saoudite. Il
disent il faut une gestion collective
des lieux saints.
Le le Hadge, ça représente à peu près 12
milliards de dollars par an. C'est le
deuxième rentrée d'argent pour l'Arabie
Saoudite. Donc on comprend que ça vexe
une seule proposition.
Et c'est l'époque où quand il y a des
grandes manifestations d'Iraniens
pendant le grand pèlerinage, les
Saoudiens n'hésitent pas à tirer. Il y a
des manifes où il y a 500 morts quand
même. Donc je voudrais qu' qu'on recale
un peu nos logiciels, tu vois. Bon euh
2e épisode de 79, c'est l'occupation de
la grande mosquée. L'occupation de la
grande mosquée, c'est intéressant parce
que de 73 79, le pays s'est enrichi
d'une manière gigantesque. Bon, alors
c'est l'époque où il découvre les
ascenseurs air conditionnés, les
bagnoles, les machins, les cél, le
cinéma, la télé. Et ce sont des
étudiants des écoles coraniques qui
justement réagissent contre cette ce
qu'ils appellent la corruption de ce du
pays qui vont occuper la grande mosquée.
La thématique de du régime c'était la
modernisation sans le changement. Ça
disait bien ce que ça voulait dire mais
enfin ceuxlà ils croyaient pas trop.
Donc ils occupent la grande mosquée
et l'occupation de la grande mosquée,
c'est un comment dire une cible très
compliquée parce que il y a quatre
minarés dans lequel il mettent des
snipers évidemment et il s'agit pas de
tirer au canon sur les minarés de la
grande mosquée. Euh ils occupent les
souterrains. Enfin bref, c'est une
opération qui évidemment se fait au
moment où il y a le plus de pèlerins
dans la grande mosquée. Bon et c'est
évidemment un traumatisme terrible.
Alors, il tente une une opération de
dégagement parce que le problème c'est
que comme c'est un lieu où la violence
ne peut pas se déployer, il faut
l'autorisation des des religieux. Bon
euh et en fait comme
une première tentative faite par les
Saoudiens échou, donc ils font appel à
aux mécréants, ils font appel en
particulier au GIGN.
Et donc le GIGN va rapidement se
convertir pour pouvoir intervenir sur le
les lieux de la grande mosquée de la
Mec. J'ai jamais su s'ils avaient été
circoncis ou pas. On m'a dit que non, je
te le dis parce que j'ai posé la
question, on m'a dit que non, ils
avaient été convertis mais pas
circoncis. Et donc ils ont fait
l'opération de dégagement. Pourquoi
c'est intéressant ? Parce que toute la
hiérarchie religieuse qui sentait bien
qui sent bien que toute façon elle
dépend aussi de la monarchie des Saoud a
trouvé toutes les explications
religieuses pour expliquer que tout ça
était légitime. Alors l'explication
qu'ils en ont donné est très rigolote
parce que
les types qui occupent la grande mosquée
se prétendent envoyer du Messie. C'est
tu sais que dans le dans la dans le
Coran, on annonce l'arrivée d'un certain
nombre de faux messies. Mais enfin bref,
ceux-là, ils se disent "Oui, oui, nous
on est là pour réhabiliter le Coran
traditionnel et d'ailleurs le Messie est
là avec nous, c'est mon cousin machin
moi."
Alors, interpeller la hiérarchie
officielle saoudienne est obligé de se
prononcer sur ce sujet et en même temps
légitimer l'action de force dans un lieu
saint. Et alors, ils disent "Oui, c'est
vrai que le prophète a annoncé l'arrivée
du Messie, mais le Messie arrivera pour
combattre les régimes corrompus de la
planète." Or, la monarchie des Saoudes
n'est pas corrompue, donc c'est pas le
médecin et donc en avant, hop, on y va
et on libère la grande mosquée. Et le 3è
épisode, c'est effectivement
alors je t'ai dit le la révolution
iranienne, l'occupation de la grande
mosquée et puis il y a un troisème
épisode aussi qui ah bah oui, c'est
l'invasion soviétique en Afghanistan en
décembre. Et donc à partir de ce moment,
on va pouvoir évacuer tous ces jeunes
gens turbulents pour les envoyer se
battre contre les saoudiens avec un
djihad parce que le djihad fait partie
de la geste nationale saoudienne. Dans
ce qu'on enseigne dans les écoles, on
explique que le régime n'a pu se
constituer qu'en faisant le djihad
contre d'autres musulmans. Mais ça il le
précise pas dans sauf dans les notes de
bas de page. Mais ça fait partie, tu
vois, dans le dans le l'idée l'idée
nationale comme le western pour les
Américains, tu le djihad fait partie de
la geste nationale saoudienne. Et donc
là, il y a une véritable opportunité
d'aller se battre et donc l'Arabie, les
Saoudiens vont être pendant pratiquement
10 ans le plus gros contingent de
combattants étrangers auprès des
mjahidines dont un fameux Ben Laden
qui reviendra ensuite sur l'avant de la
scène. Donc l'Arabie Saoudite a été à
joué de tout cette gamme là,
c'est-à-dire elle était la puissance
anticommuniste du monde arabe. Donc elle
était dans le camp du bien, elle
fournissait des troupes et cetera et
elle faisait une propagande religieuse
qui était censée combattre en
particulier dans l'ensemble du monde
arabe, la poussé de gauche qui en
particulier se traduisait dans les
universités par des mouvements de
contestation et cetera. Donc on s'est
volontairement masqué le rôle nuisible
de l'Arabie Saoudite et le paroxyme de
tout ça, ça a été le 11 septembre.
Le 11 septembre, il y a 15 Saoudiens sur
19 terroristes dans les les attentats du
11 septembre. et Bouche fait un discours
remarquable en janvier expliquant que
l'axe du mal c'est l'Iran, l'Irak et la
Corée du Nord. Tu vois un peu la tête
des Coréens quand ils ont appris que les
attentats du 11 septembre c'était eux.
Bon
tiens, j'ouvre une parenthèse pendant
que tu parles de de ça. On va te passer
une petite vidéo.
Je vais te la montrer sur mon écran. Je
vais je vais tourner mon écran et tu vas
me dire ce que tu en penses. D'accord.
Allez, on envoie la sauce les gars.
He said, "Sir, you got you got to come
in and talk to me a second." I said,
"Well, you're too busy." He said, "No,
no." He says, "We've made the decision
we're going to war with Iraq. This was
honor about the 20th of September.
I said, "We're going to war with Iraq."
Why?
He said, "I don't know."
He said, "I guess they don't know what
else to do."
So, uh, I said, "Well, did they find
some information collect connecting
Saddam to Alqeda?" He said, "No, no." He
says, "There's nothing new that way.
They just made the decision to go to war
with Iraq."
He said, "I guess it's like we don't
know what to do about terrorists, but we
got a good military and we can take down
governments." And he said, "I guess if
the only two you have is a hammer, every
problem has to look like a nail."
So, I came back to see him a few weeks
later and by that time we were bombing
in Afghanistan, I said, "Are we still
going to war with Iraq?" And he said,
"Oh, it's worse than that." He said, he
reached over on his desk. picked up a
piece of paper and he said I just he
said I just got this down from upstairs
meaning the Secretary Defense office
today and he said this a memo that
describes how we're going to take out
seven countries in years with Syrieban
Libya Somalia and finishing
tu sais qui c'est général West ou
qui était chef agent de temps en Europe
n'importe
qui.
Qu'est-ce que tu en penses ?
Ben moi, je trouve que ça traduit
quelque chose d'une orientation
diplomatique des États-Unis à laquelle
on ne s'est pas suffisamment intéressé.
Moi, je travaille en ce moment sur les
radicalismes religieux. Il y en a un en
particulier qui ne fait pas l'objet
d'une analyse de nature géopolitique,
c'est le radicalisme des néovangéliques
américains. Les néovangéliques
américains pratiquement euh commencent
avec Carter. D'ailleurs, le time fait
une couverture en disant c'est l'un des
des
avant que tu commences ton à me
dérouler.
Ouais. Qu'un général de l'armée
américaine avec quand même quelques
petites épaules sur les épaulettes
balance ça et que ça finit sur l'Iran,
cette vidéo date de 2007.
Ça t'interpelle pas ?
Si, ça m'interpelle mais justement c'est
pour ça que je reviens en arrière parce
que d'abord c'est une vieille tendance
de ce qu'on a appelé la volonté. Comment
ils appelé ça ? d'abord le régime
change, c'est-à-dire le droit que se
donne un état de changer le régime
politique dans notre état. Et le
deuxième, c'était l'été du Greed Middle
East, c'est-à-dire l'idée chez les
Républicains poussé en particulier par
ces néoangéliques dont je parle là, euh
de remodeler complètement le
Moyen-Orient.
Et alors, pourquoi j'insiste sur les
névangéliques ? Parce que eux, ils
considèrent, si tu veux, que la
constitution du grand Israël est l'étape
absolument nécessaire pour l'arrivée du
Messie. Donc, ils sont dans une logique
totalement théologique. Totalement,
hein. Il y a des discours de euh Farwell
qui est un de ses grands
téléprédicateurs qui explique que tout
ça d'abord va permettre de christianiser
le Moyen-Orient et puis qu'en plus euh
ça va permettre de redessiner tout ça.
Il y avait un un consultant français
d'ailleurs à la Rand à l'époque qui
s'appelait euh
Rand Corporation,
pardon,
la Rand Corporation. Corporation, un
français qui s'appelait Laurent Muravie
qui avait fait un exposé justement pour
redessiner tout le Moyen-Orient en
prévoyant en particulier de découper
l'Arabie Saoudite.
Malheureusement, sa présentation a fuité
dans les journaux, ce qui fait que ça a
fait un gros scandale et le mec s'est
fait virer. Mais le type est un liod,
c'est un type très proche du Liqu et
donc qui en gros appliquait ce qui
devait avait probablement été négocié
entre cette frange républicaine très
marquée par les néoangéliques et le
Liquoud sur comment il faut remodéler
tout le Moyen-Orient pour pouvoir
assurer la sécurité d'Israël. Et donc on
est dans une situation extraordinaire où
tu vois ces types se se prennent la
carte mais après tout c'est ce qu'on a
fait avec Pico. On prend la carte, on se
met sur une table, on refait on
redessine les traits et cetera et on
redessine tout le moyen d'Orient.
Après ça, quand tu raisonnes en face de
gens comme ça, renverse la perspective
et mets-toi du côté iranien. Bon, quand
tu te mets du côté iranien, tu te dis
"Ce pays, ça fait 50 ans qu'on l'emmerde
parce qu'il a du pétrole. 53 Mossadeg,
démocratiquement élu veut nationaliser
le pétrole. Erreur majeure, coup d'état
de la CIA, il est renversé. Euh, on
redéploye un peu le pétrole, hein, c'est
quand même plutôt qui recueille le truc
et BP qui se fait un peu évincer. Bon,
il est renversé en en 53, il se tape 25
ans de dictature du chat. 25 ans de
dictature du chat avec une police
politique qui s'appelait la Savac qui
allait assassiner les opposants à
l'étranger, mais enfin ça c'est du
détail. Euh, et puis le type qu'on
présentait comme moderniste. Bon, en 79,
il y a la révolution dont on peut pas ne
pas dire qu'elle a été démocratique. Il
y avait 2 millions de personnes dans les
rues de Terran. Et quand la région d'Air
France arrive à l'aéroport et queil
débarque Roménie, la France est portée
au nu. L'ambassadeur tous les jours des
œillers blancs devant son ambassade et
cetera et cetera. Or, en 6 mois, on va
se retourner et soutenir l'Irak contre
l'Iran, c'est-à-dire qu'on va soutenir
au nu l'agresseur contre l'agressé, ce
qui est quand même une performance. On
avait jamais fait ça en droit
international. Donc, on va mettre sous
embargo l'Iran et on va aider l'Irak.
Bon, il se trouve que l'Irak nous devait
de l'argent pour les contrats
d'armement, hein. Donc, c'est sûr que si
un pays te doit de l'argent pour des
contrats d'armement et qui perd la
guerre, c'est ça fait des ordre. Donc,
on est allé très loin dans l'engagement,
c'est-à-dire qu'on est allé jusqu'à non
seulement fournir les meilleures armes,
mais en plus, on leur a fourni des super
étendards en ligne dans la dans la
l'armée de l'air française, enfin dans
la marine, c'était des avions embarqués
avec des navigateurs français à bord
pour que le ciblage sur les pétroliers
soit juste. Donc, tu vois jusqu'où on
est allé. Bon, en échange de ça, on a eu
des attentats encore une fois sur le
territoire français et quand on a envoyé
un diplomate là-bas à Terran pour dire
quand même c'est pas bien de faire des
attentats chez nous, les types nous ont
dit "Mais attendez, c'est vous qui êtes
un état terroriste. Vous abritez les
moujahidines du peuple qui ont tué chez
nous un président de la République.
Notre guide de la révolution est emputé
d'abras parce qu'il a été l'objet d'un
attentat. Et on a à peu près 10000
personnes tuées par des attentats
organisés par les moujidines du peuple.
Comme tu vois, la douche froide a dû
être sérieuse pour notre diplomate
puisque tout à coup on lui renvoyait
cette espèce d'irresponsabilité de notre
diplomatie.
Donc quand tu te mets dans cette
situation et que tu te dis c'est un pays
qui depuis 50 ans a subi 8 ans de
guerre, deux fois la guerre de 14 quand
même he qui a fait à peu près 500 à
600000 morts en Iran. Tu es un homme
d'état, tu te dis mais le seul moyen de
ne plus être emmerdé dans mon pays, je
peux pas me payer une armée
conventionnelle, c'est trop cher, donc
je fais la bombe. Tu vois la
problématique ? On est dans ce genre de
situation où tous ces gens bien pensant
qui t'expliquent qu'on est là pour la
sécurité internationale, il t'expliquent
que si l'Iran fait la bombe, c'est que
c'est une puissance déstabilisatrice.
On sait qu'à Israël a peu près 200 têtes
disponibles. Mais évidemment, tu
comprends la démarche importante que
avait ce type à la rand,
c'est-à-dire il ne peut pas qu'il y a
une seconde puissance nucléaire dans la
région. Donc, il y a une solution assez
simple, c'est de proposer un plan de
dénuclisation de l'ensemble du
Moyen-Orient
sans Israël. Ah ben non, en incluant
Israël à ce moment-là, tu as un plan de
dénuclisation et tu as un système où
effectivement l'Iran n'a plus aucune
raison de garder n'a jamais reconnu
avoir des tête.
Non, il a jamais reconnu. D'ailleurs, il
a pas signé le traité de non
prolifération. Donc effectivement, c'est
un secret de polychinel puisque tu sais
qu'il y a un ingénieur
israélien qui est en prison justement
pour avoir révélé que la centrale de
d'Imona était une centrale qui
produisait de l'argement enrichi. Donc
faut faire des bours. Il est en
Ils avaient pas un peu trafiqué aussi
avec l'Afrique du Sud pour ce type
d'affaires là ? Non.
C'est possible parce que la question
c'est où est-ce qu'ils ont fait leurs
essais ? Tu sais qu'en général quand
pour faire avoir une bombe qui marche,
il vaut mieux avoir procédé à des
essais. Donc soit ils les ont fait au
Nevada dans le avec les Américains, soit
ils les ont fait en Afrique du Sud. Les
deux hypothèses sont possibles. On pense
à l'Afrique du Sud mais il y a pas il y
a pas de à l'époque c'était l'époque où
l'Afrique du Sud effectivement essayait
de se doter de la bombe. Donc c'est
possible.
Donc pour revenir à notre général Wesley
Clark 2007, il nous annonce quand même
des pays qui allaient être déstabilisés.
On voit que l'histoire l' absou à peu
près 80 %.
L'Iran, est-ce que c'est vraiment la
cible des pays occidentaux ? Est-ce que
c'est la cible de ce que tu décris comme
les les néoangélistes religieux
radicalisés chrétiens ? Est-ce que c'est
un un point de vue plus large ? Est-ce
que c'est une vision à 30 ans de la
géopolitique d'une retérraformation du
Moyen-Orient
pour des histoires de de pognon, de pipe
ou de choses comme ça ou c'est
simplement idéologique jusqu'au bout des
ongles ?
C'est un mélange d'idéologie et de
théologie. C'est-à-dire que on voit bien
que la liste des pays, c'est quand même
les pays arabes qui entourent Israël. Il
faut quand même penser que par exemple
dans la décennie 90, c'est-à-dire le
moment où l'URSS disparaît, bon les
cercles stratégiques ont plus d'ennemis.
Quand on est dans un cercle stratégique
et qu'il y a plus d'ennemis, soit tu
licencies, soit tu inventes des ennemis.
C'est la deux hypothèses. Donc c'est
l'époque où euh on sort le clash des
civilisations, tu sais, dans lequel
Hton, c'est ça,
pardon.
Huntington.
Huntington, oui, exactement. Traduit en
35 langues quand même, hein. Ça veut
dire que ça a été un petit succès. Euh
et dans lequel il dit la civilisation
musulmane est structurellement
agressive. Donc tu vois le postulat
comment il est posé le fait que les
occidentaux enfin les puissances depuis
les cinq puissances member
une cinquantaine de conflits hors au nu
si tu veux depuis 45 ça rentre pas dans
la réflexion de Huntington donc il dit
la civilisation musulmane est
structurellement agressive bon donc tu
vois il construit un postulat qui est le
postulat classique de fabrication de
l'ennemis
donc que autour de ça ce soit conjugué
si tu veux à la fois des républicains
qui se disent mais après tout
Maintenant, nous sommes la puissance de
la planète, donc on peut refaire la
carte à volonté.
Euh deuxième chose, ces théologiens qui
effectivement sont des gens qui ont
pensé, il y a eu ce qu'on appelle aux
États-Unis des grands réveils,
c'est-à-dire des moments où il y a eu
tout à coup des poussées de religiosité.
Bon, le dernier en épisode étant
évidemment la guerre froide puisque la
guerre froide, c'était la menace de la
destruction absolue et donc il y a une
espèce de poussée de religiosité. Si la
fin du monde est pour bientôt, autant
bien se préparer. Et sont donc nés à ce
moment-là tout un certain nombre de
téléprédicateurs qui nous fascinent
parce que ce sont des mecs qui sont
capables de faire des discours dans des
méga church, tu sais, devant 40000
personnes qui font une analyse
géopolitique et cetera et cetera. Voilà
et que ces gens-là aient pensaient,
comme je te le disais tout à l'heure,
que la constitution du grand Israël
était l'étape indispensable pour la le
retour du Messie. C'est un discours qui
nous nous étonne beaucoup mais qui était
une espèce de fond de commerce dans
lequel un certain nombre de ces gens-là
se sont fait d'ailleurs des grosses
fortune. Je te conseille ce ce genre-là
parce que ça peut rapporter gros. Chez
les télépicateurs arabes, c'est pareil
hein. En général, ils expliquent que si
tu donnes, ça te fait gagner le paradis.
On avait connu les indulgences, ils ont
perfectionné le système. Donc ces
gens-là ont mûri cette pensée et ils ont
alimenté le les républicains pour
l'essentiel. La première des
concrétisations, c'est Rigan qui
commence pour la première fois à parler
de l'axe du mal, le camp du bien contre
l'axe du mal. Ça utilise des termes
moraux. Ça va ensuite réapparaître avec
le père Bush mais surtout ça va
apparaître avec le deuxième avec George
W. Bush et puis évidemment aujourd'hui
avec Trump qui s'est constitué autour de
lui un conseil évangélique dans lequel
tu retrouves un certain nombre de ces
prédicateurs dont ceux par exemple qui
ont expliqué que le 11 septembre était
la punition de Dieu sur l'Amérique à
cause des homosexuels, de l'avortement
et cetera et cetera. Euh tu as ceux qui
expliquent effectivement que la guerre
d'Irak va permettre la christianisation
euh le prosélitisme en Irak.
Il y avait ceux qui expliquaient qu'il
fallait libérer la femme afghane. Tu
vois, par exemple, des choses comme ça.
Donc, il y avait toute cette espèce de
fond idéologique qui encore une fois
légitimait l'utilisation de la violence
puisque c'est le camp du bien. Bon ben
cette tendance là de la société
américaine quand nos chers présidents
Hollande et Sarkozi se sont alignés sur
cette lignée là, si tu veux, ils ne
mesuraient pas l'arrière-fond
idéologique que ça représentait. Et cet
arrière-fond idéologique, on le voit
bien en activité. Ils ont envahi
illégalement l'Irak. Le dernier sursaut
de politique de diplomatie indépendante
française, c'est Chirac. Et après ça, on
a eu droit à un French bashing aux
États-Unis. Chc de Villepin et et tout
ça. Quand tu vois Macron avec Trump
planter des arbres, se balader,
montrer cette grande amitié française
depuis la faillette,
ça te fait penser à quoi ? Et à la suite
des frappes en Syrie, c'est parce que
Trump a besoin d'un allié à peu près
crédible avec une historicité permettant
de briller au sein de ses frontières.
C'est parce que il est rejeté, il n'est
pas légitime en tant que président
Trump. Et la France sert de faire
valoir. C'est quoi ?
Je crois que de toute façon, on projette
sur les États-Unis ce qu'on a envie d'y
voir. Trump est légitime. Il légitime.
Il a été élu par un processus
constitutionnel. C'est pas à nous d'en
juger. Bon, il représente une forme
d'Amérique profonde. Ce qui est quand
même très étonnant, c'est que ce soit
cette Amérique profonde que nous on ne
connaît pas parce que évidemment ce
qu'on connaît c'est les gens de la côte
est ou de la côte ouest. C'est des gens
comme nous quoi qui savent qui sont
propres sur eux, qui parlent notre
langage et cetera. Moi, j'étais très
frappé par exemple que l'essentiel de
nos sing tank français et des contacts
avec les sing tank américains qui
pensaient comme eux au lieu d'avoir avec
l'American Enterprise, avec le Heritage
Foundation et cetera, c'est-à-dire tous
ces singaient le parti républicain,
c'est-à-dire ceux qui redessinaient la
planète, on allait chercher confirmation
de ce qu'on pensait d'près des Singtanks
qui pensaient comme nous. Or, les votes
de de Trump, c'est le vote de l'Amérique
profonde, c'est-à-dire des mecs qui
perdaient leur boulot parce qu'ils
voyaient leurs usines partir au Mexique,
qui avaient l'impression que les on les
protégeait pas, qui avait l'impression
que la l'Amérique est menacé parce que
c'est une thématique classique en
Amérique, hein. Ce pays étant le
meilleur du monde. L'autre ne peut être
qu'un envieux, un jaloux, un méchant ou
un ennemi. Bon et donc tout ce c'est ce
vote là que Trump a a su parfaitement
cristalliser. Ce qui est très rigolo
dans Trump, c'est que c'est un type qui
est capable de dire une chose et son
contraire avec la même assurance.
pendant sa campagne électorale, il
disait "On va faire son compte à
l'Arabie Saoudite et puis tu vois que
dès son premier voyage en Arabie
Saoudite, il devient le grand ami de
l'Arabie Saoudite. Donc il est capable
de dire une chose et son contraire avec
un public qui après tout étant donné la
connaissance qu'il a du monde
international
a tout à fait les chances de se dire bon
c'est notre présidente donc il a raison.
Il faut penser que la moitié des
congressistes américains n'ont pas de
passeport par exemple hein. Ça veut dire
que c'est quand même pas un pays qui est
tourné vers l'extérieur. Ça, on en
reparlera dans la dernière partie de
l'entretien.
Le rapport de de l'Amérique au reste du
monde est très étonnant. Moi, je me
souviens d'être état au d'être aux
États-Unis dans un taxi
conduit par un sud-américain. Je
commence à lui parler en espagnol, il
répondait en anglais. C'est-à-dire qu'il
voulait absolument montrer qu'il était
américain. Ce processus là, il faut le
comprendre. On est face à quelque chose
qui est une identité très puissante,
qui est très fière d'elle-même, mais ça
on en reparlera tout à l'heure. Mais
cette identité si tu veux qui qui a
quand même Pourquoi est-on si fier
d'identité américaine quand on sait que
l'histoire de ce pays, ça a quand même
été d'être esclavagiste,
ségrégationniste jusqu'aux années 60,
génocidaire à l'égard des Indiens,
raciste encore aujourd'hui et
impérialiste, ça comme un continuum.
Donc je me suis dit c'est très étonnant
pourquoi est-ce que les Américains sont
si fiers d'être Américains et que nous
on est dans un état d'esprit où on se
fustige
et pourquoi nous on leur donne entre
guillemets pas la leçon nous le pays des
droits de l'homme ?
Oh tu sais quand en 48 on cite la la
charte internationale des droits de
l'homme tu as cinq pays membres qui la
signent. Il y en a deux qui sont les
plus grandes puissances coloniales de la
planète, la France et la
Grande-Bretagne. Tu as un pays les
États-Unis qui est quand même encore
raciste puisqueil y a des lois
ségrégationnistes, hein. Tu sais que
juste un petit retour en arrière, moi
j'étais en Algérie pendant la guerre
d'indépendance. Mon père était
journaliste, il recevait des
journalistes américains qui lui disaient
"Mais enfin, vous êtes une société
raciste, regardez comment vous traitez
les Arabes et cetera." Il avait raison.
Mais si tu vois en Algérie, il y a
jamais eu des lois qui interdisaient aux
Arabes de monter dans des bus ou de
boire à certaines fontaines ou d'entrer
dans certains hôtels. Donc ce type nous
parlait d'une espèce de légitimité qui
était spécifiquement américaine sans
regarder quelle était le les limites de
son propre système. Et pour en terminer
dans le tour de table, donc il y avait
la Russie de Staline parmi les
signataires, ce qui était pas exactement
une grande démocratie, et puis la Chine
de Changai. Donc si tu veux le fait de
signer des textes sur les droits de
l'homme n'engage jamais personne. Je te
dis on était la deuxè puissance
coloniale de la planète et pourtant on
reconnaissait le droit des peuples à
disposer d'eux-même. Donc s'il te plaît
la vie internationale est faite pour
qu'on se raconte des histoires.
Le on ouvre une petite parenthèse
histoire de te déconcentrer un peu si
c'est possible. Les Russes, la Russie,
comment ça se passe ? affairesal
ces histoires de guerre chimiques, ces
histoires de de frappes chimiques, ces
histoires de on va chercher l'épreuve
après avoir bombardé sur place.
On est dans de la la de la propagande de
guerre la papa. On est dans quoi ?
Euh je sais pas pour la faire ce qui
parle. Moi ce qui me frappe sur le cas
des Russes, c'est que
à partir du moment où la guerre froide
se termine, bon donc si tu veux cette
espèce de régulation du monde qui
faisait qu'on se partageait la planète
et puis on disait celui-là c'est chez
moi, ça c'est chez moi et cetera. Bon
les étés, tu vois les conforts que que
représentaient cette ces doubles
puissances disparaissent
progressivement. Bon d'abord il apparaît
un monde utile et un monde inutile,
c'est-à-dire le Congo, ils peuvent se
massacrer, c'est des noirs, c'est pas
grave.
2 millions et demi de morts 13000
enfants enlevés, c'est pas grave.
Par contre, il y a il y a une un pays
utile, c'est-à-dire c'est cela sur
lesquels on va se disputer. Bon,
deuxième caractéristique de la
disparition de la guerre froide, c'est
le retour du temps long. Et le temps
long, ça veut dire que des fractures qui
étaient masquées par le la guerre froide
tout à couraraissent. Une de ces
fractures, la première qui vient qui
nous vient en pleine figure, c'est
lagoslavie. 50 ans de titisme, on s'est
dit quand même ces gens-là, ils doivent
quand même pouvoir se s'entendre entre
eux. Or, tu as une population qui parle
tous le cerveau croate, les uns étant
catholiques romains, les autres étant
catholiques orthodoxes et les troisème
étant musulmans. Alors, ça a été une des
guerres les plus violentes avec le
comment dire les massacres les plus
importants depuis la Seconde Guerre
mondiale. Donc, si tu veux, cette ce
retour du temps long, ça veut dire
révéler des fractures qu'on ignorait euh
parce que finalement euh bah c'est comme
ça qu'on écrit les papiers pour un
ministre, hein, tu sais, on reprend le
papier précédent, on le met à jour et
puis il part avec. Mais ce retour sur ce
que pourrait être le monde à venir est
très compliqué.
Et donc pour le cas des Russes, à partir
du moment où le l'URSS disparaît, si tu
veux tout à coup réapparaissent toutes
ces fracture. Il y a quand même 14 états
qui naissent de la fracture de l'URSS.
Et la caractéristique de cette
disparition de l'URSS, c'est que tous
ces territoires de colonisation russe,
notamment en Asie centrale qui étaient
des colonisations du 19e siècle, tout à
coup deviennent des États indépendants.
Quand nous on perd l'Algérie, le Maroc
et la Tunisie, il y a la Méditerranée
entre nous. pour les Russes quand ils
perdent le Kazakhstan, l'Azerbaïjan et
cetera et cetera, tout à coup c'est leur
c'est leur littoral si tu veux, c'est
leur leur continent si tu veux qui se
parcéléralise. Donc ça c'est un choc
traumatique très important. Deuxième
caractéristique, c'est l'époque yine,
c'est-à-dire le pillage de la Russie par
tout ce qu'on a appelé les oligarques
avec un type qui était moitié sous tout
le temps. Et donc tout à coup, ce pays
est pillé. Quand dans ce paysage là
apparaît un type qui s'appelle Poutine
qui va commencer par Fotantol, un type
de Yukol qui s'appelait je sais plus
comment, enfin il avait une bonne
gueule. Donc si tu veux pour nous
c'était une victime de Poutine. Or ce
type avait pillé si tu veux la ressource
pétrolière de la Russie. Bon donc quand
même quand Poutine lutte contre les
oligarques si tu veux on considère qu'il
est pas bien. C'est quand même un peu
paradoxal moi. Et donc il y a une espèce
de construction du mal qui est une
espèce de de trou noir dans notre
psychologie qui d'ailleurs commence en
1054. C'est-à-dire quand il y a la
fracture entre l'Empire romain d'Orient
et l'Empire romain d'Occident. Parce
qu'à ce moment-là, si tu veux qu'on ait
une chrétienté là-bas, alors que nous on
est en pleine déliquence, la Rome est en
pleine difficulté, la papauté n'existe
plus. Et 2è épisode qui est une espèce
de marque psychologique de l'église
orthodoxe, c'est 1204, la 4e croisade.
C'est-à-dire qu'on détourne la croisade
non pas pour aller se battre contre les
musulmans, mais pour prendre
Constantinople.
On on l'a oublié celle la 4e croisade,
je sais pas pourquoi. Et donc si tu veux
pour eux c'est une marque importante
parce que ça voulait dire que cette
deuxième capitale de la chrétienté les
autres chrétiens étaient capables de la
prendre simplement pour des motifs de
fric pour des motifs d'économique pour
des motifs de domination théologique
aussi. Et donc là tu sais qu'à ce
moment-là le la papauté passe enfin pas
la papauté le le métropolite de
Constantinop va passer à Moscou quand
Constantinople va disparaître en 1254 3e
épisode. Quand les Turcs prennent
Constantinople, les occidentaux bougent
pas. Bon donc que chez les Russes, il y
a l'idée que si tu veux l'Occident n'a
cessé de les de les abandonner ou de les
trahir. C'est une identité formidable.
Moi, je me souviens euh j'étais en
Roumanie juste après la révolution
contre Cheoesku.
Je me retrouve dans le bureau dans le le
le la maison du métropolite
roumain orthodoxe roumain. Bon, c'est
une école, c'est une église autocéphale.
Donc, c'était le chef de l'église
roumaine.
Je savais pas trop pourquoi j'étais là,
je savais pas trop quoi dire. Enfin
bref, on se met à causer et il me dit
maintenant il faut se méfier du retour
de l'impérialisme.
Alors, j'étais un peu comme ça, un peu
désorienté. Je dis impérialisme, pensez
quoi les les Russes ? Il me dit "Non,
Rome,
tu vois, c'est-à-dire que sa structure à
lui, c'est cette animosité qui s'est
créée à travers l'histoire avec la
volonté de domination de la papoté."
Donc si on prend pas en compte cette
identité, c'est-à-dire cette à la fois
cette espèce de blessure de l'identité
russe orthodoxe par rapport à
l'Occident, que si on prend pas en
compte le fait de cette profonde
humiliation qui a été pour la Russie
l'époque de Yelsine et tout à coup ce
sursaut national que représente Poutine,
on fait de Poutine un ennemi. Mais que
Poutine soit dire populaire en Russie,
dire il y a rien d'extraordinaire.
Simplement on fait en Russie comme on
fait en New York Soviétique en URS aux
États-Unis. C'est-à-dire, on connaît
tous New York, donc on connaît les
États-Unis. Là, les gens qui sont à
Moscou, ils connaissent tous la Russie.
Le problème, c'est que les mecs, ils
sont en Sibérie, si tu veux, ce qui se
passe à Moscou, ils s'en foutent. Ce qui
les intéresse, c'est que effectivement
l'économie russe reparte qui a des des
produits dans les magasins. Tu sais que
par exemple, pendant l'époque Yelsine,
il y avait 40 % de l'économie russe qui
était démonétisée.
Ça voulait dire que tu allais acheter
des pommes de terre en vendant des
lacés, que tu devais échanger une
casserole pour avoir un parapluie. Bon,
c'est une période où on a du mal à
souvenir. Ça nous rappelle l'occupation,
l'étiquet de rationnement. et cetera,
ben pour eux, il y a une espèce de
sursaut national et cette humiliation là
qui était la rétraction coloniale plus
la difficulté de l'époque de de Yelsine
plus cette identité que représente
Poutine aujourd'hui, ben c'est un fait à
prendre en compte. Il faut donc il faut
pas le diaboliser. Quand par exemple en
Ukraine
préconisation pour pour parler avec
Poutine ou parler avec les Russes,
pardon,
des préconisations pour leur parler,
bah c'est pas de les prendre pour des
imbéciles ni pour des ennemis. Je te
cite un exemple. quand ils font la
sécession de l'Ukraine orientale ou
quand ils font la sécession de la
Crimée, tu sais bien comme c'est
diabolique, ils ont fait un référendum
90 % hop, ils font l'annexion de la
Crimée. Ça me rappelle un vague
souvenir, c'est-à-dire le moment où on a
fait nous le le référendum à Mayotte,
hein, tu sais,
c'est pas les échelles, c'est les comor
les comors.
Et comme Mayotte a voté pour
l'attachement à la France, mais tout le
reste a voté pour l'indépendance, mais
on est on s'est assis sur le principe de
la souveraineté des États. Donc on a dit
Mayotte est française et Mayotte
aujourd'hui c'est la plus grosse
maternité de France.
C'est aussi la plus grosse porte
d'entrée pour l'immigration. Non.
Bah oui justement c'est pour ça que je
te dis la plus grosse maternité parce
que si tu veux les femmes viennent
accoucher, elles repartent. C'est
qu'elle nous laisse les enfants, ils
seront français donc moins on assure
leur avenir. Donc tu vois ce genre
d'autre chose où on dit mais ça c'est
pas bien ce que vous avez fait mais sans
en oubliant tout ce qu'on a fait nous
c'est extrêmement pénible parce que il y
a pas de raison que les Russes soient
plus idiots que nous. Ils se souviennent
d'épisodes où nous-même on a fait des
actes.
Comment leur parler ? mis à part le fait
de pas les prendre pour des débiles
mentaux.
Bah moi je crois que si tu veux, il faut
pas commencer à partir avec l'idée que
les Russes sont par nature différent de
nous. La meilleure preuve c'est celle
que je viens de te donner. Si tu veux
c'est par exemple dans les années, il y
a une dizaine d'années, j'avais écrit un
bouquin sur la fabrication de l'ennemi,
le cas russe. Bon, j'étais frappé du
fait queon parlait, tu sais, des mafieux
russes qui étaient en sentier arrivé sur
la côte d'Azur en particulier, mais
c'était une époque où c'était la mafia
italienne qui tuait dans les rues
d'Allemagne où il y avait une pizzeria
où il y avait eu si bord, tu vois. Bon
mais enfin c'est pas grave. C'était les
Russes qui étaient inquiétants. Bon euh
il y avait les oligarques qui arrivaient
qui allaient donner de l'argent qui avit
partout et cetera mais c'était de
l'argent sale. C'était pas comme les
gens du golf. C'est là les gens du golf
ils étaient bien. Il y avait le fait que
Poutine était un ancien officier du KGB
mais enfin le père Bouche était patron
de la CIA. Mais enfin c'est pas grave,
faut pas tout mélanger, tu vois. Et donc
il y a le processus de construction d'un
ennemi qui a commencé très longtemps
avant avec la Russie. Donc ne pas les
prendre pour des ennemis et dire qu'ils
ont un droit de comment dire tu sais en
plus dernier épisode qui était très
important pour eux c'est que l'extension
de l'OTAN c'est fait d'un seul coup tu
sais avec tous les anciens pays
satellites mais que les Américains ont
voulu poser sur la table aussi
l'intégration de l'Ukraine dans l'OTAN.
Bon or l'Ukraine c'est le cœur
historique de la Russie puisque c'est à
partir de ce moment-là quoi se
constituait du chef de Moscou et cetera.
Donc si tu veux touses ces choses-là
sont des choses qui sont extrêmement
humiliantes parce qu'elles sont dans le
temps long et qu'elles constituent
l'identité culturelle russe. Donc si on
arrive là-bas en lui disant écoutez, on
va vous dire ce que vous devez faire,
c'est les prendre pour des imbéciles et
c'est ça la faute principale.
Est-ce que les vrais imbéciles sont au
sein même de nos cellules de prospective
comme au dorsais ou est-ce qu'on recrute
que des consanguins qui ont une vision
endoctrinée et formatée ? Est-ce que
Non, je crois pas. Je crois qu'il y a
des gens intelligents. C'est le système
qui est bête. C'est-à-dire euh
tu es indulgent là. Non.
Pardon ?
Tu es indulgent ? Non
non, je crois pas. Si tu veux là, je
discuter avec un ancien ambassadeur qui
m'expliquait par exemple
quel pays
il était ambassadeur de France en Chine.
Bon, il est un type qui connaît
parfaitement la Chine. Il parlait de
chinois, il y avait été comme VI et
cetera et cetera.
Mais si tu veux, il expliquait par
exemple dans un dans ses mémoires qu'à
au moment de la venue de Mitteran par
exemple,
il y avait Jean-Daniel du Nouvels
et donc il avait invité un certain
nombre d'intellectuels chinois qui
étaient là pour honorer Jean-Daniel.
Bon, il commence à parler. Or, il venait
de terminer le procès de la bande des
quatre notamment Ti qui était la femme
de Maouetung qui avait été une des pires
pendant la révolution culturelle. Et
donc dans autour de la table, tu avais
des intellectuels chinois qui avaient
été en camp de concentration. Il y en
avait même un dont on avait cassé les
jambes si tu veux dans les séances de
torture. Et Jean-Daniel expliquait le
rôle positif qu'avait joué Chun Ching
dans la révolution culturelle. Et il
parlait du Nouvels comme si le nouvels
était un média international que tout
chinois devait connaître. Et donc tu
avais une espèce de séance dans laquelle
il y avait une prétention, une arrogance
française en face de type qui eux
avaient payé dans leur chair si tu veux
la révolution culturelle. Il fallait
expliquer Jean-Daniel expliquait que le
nouvel homme s'était divisé entre deux
tendances parce que il y avait KS Carol
qui disait que la révolution culturelle
était une étape importante dans la
construction du communisme et il y avait
Olivier, il y avait Ro mais pas Jean Roi
qui disait pas du tout c'est une période
de répression et ce type était en train
d'expliquer aux Chinois ce qu'il fallait
penser de la révolution culturelle.
Donc oui, ce que ta question est vraie
mais c'est à la fois c'est tout un
système si tu veux qui français qui fait
que la France ayant été pays des droits
de l'ombre en permanence du conseil de
sécurité puissance nucléaire fait
qu'elle est au centre de la planète
plate.
Il y a pas que les Saoudiens qui pensent
que la planète est plate. Nous aussi on
le pense. Et donc tu as cette espèce de
prétention qui fait que tu ne peux pas
quand tu es ambassadeur dire à ton
ministre "Vous savez je suis dans une
région du monde où de toute façon ce que
vous allez dire ne pèse absolument pas."
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ? étais
obligé de dire, j'ai tenu une réunion
avec les les
ambassadeurs de l'Union européenne qui
tous attendent la prise de position de
notre ministre. Moi, je me suis amusé
une fois à écrire un télégramme
diplomatique sans objet.
Donc, tu vois, un télégramme
diplomatique sans objet, ça veut dire
que tu as plus qu'à mettre le sujet et
puis la date et c'est bon. Alors, ça
commence très simplement. La France
Montpmanent du Conseil de sécurité,
puissance nucléaire, pays des droits de
l'homme ne peut pas se désintéresser de
cette région du monde dans laquelle elle
compte tant d'intérêts. Les
francophiles, ils sont nombreux.
D'ailleurs, ma réunion avec les derniers
et cetera et cetera et cetera. Et je te
dis, tu as qu'à préciser l'objet. Ça
peut être la guerre de la morue ou ça
peut être la crise en Afghanistan.
On fait comment pour changer tout ça ?
Il faut il faut ruer dans les brancards.
Je ne sais pas. Les Américains ont une
qualité si tu veux par rapport à nous,
c'est que la critique est destinée à
améliorer le système qui est le meilleur
du monde. En France, la critique, tu as
deux argumentaires qui bloquent toute
critique. C'est soit tu craches dans la
soupe, soit tu es un envieux, un jaloux,
déçu, un aigri. Bon, c'est-à-dire qu'on
nexamine pas ton argument, on examine ta
position. Tu vois le truc ? Donc tu veux
finir ta carrière tranquillement dans
ton administration, tu lèves pas trop la
tête, tu essayes avec intelligence de
dire "Vous savez, monsieur le ministre
toutefois néanmoins et cetera et
cetera." Bon, il y en a conditionnel est
une langue importante pour le français.
Donc tu fais des trucs qui te disent qui
essayent de faire comprendre que mais
moi je me souviens très bien d'une
discussion, j'étais au ministère de la
défense où on avait fait un papier qui
était très inquiétant sur une situation,
je me souviens plus même plus laquelle.
et un membre du cabinet sort d'une
réunion de cabinet, il me dit "Le
ministre a décidé que alors je disais
c'est dommage que nos ennemis lisent pas
les notes du ministre parce que sinon
ils saurait à quoi s'en tenir." Tu vois
la prétention intellectuelle qu'il y
avait derrière.
Bon ben ça ça veut dire qu'à un moment
redescendre sur terre la France n'est
plus une moyenne puissance, c'est une
moyenne impuissance. Simplement, il faut
repenser toute la diplomatie à partir de
ce constat. C'est-à-dire quels sont les
moyens sur lesquels on peut
effectivement agir et ne pas prétendre
que parce qu'on a une place assise au
conseil de sécurité, il faut être
partout.
Aucune préconisation pour la société
civile pour se réapproprier sa parole
diplomatique.
Si, je crois que de toute façon la
caractéristique de la société civile
française comme d'ailleurs des sociétés
civiles européennes, c'est qu'elles
existent internationalement. Quand je te
dis que l'Amérique est un pays très
fermé sur lui-même, c'est quand même une
caractéristique différente pour nous.
Deux différences essentielles par
rapport à la société américaine. Les
américains savent pas ce que c'est que
la guerre sur leur territoire. Leur
dernier conflit, c'est la guerre de
sécession. Et le dernier ancien
combattant, il est mort en 1933.
Donc depuis ce moment-là, ils savent pas
ce que c'est une ville détruite rasée,
les que de rationnement, les tickets,
les points d'eau et cetera. Bon, la
guerre a été médiatisée par le cinéma.
Ça c'est notre différence essentielle.
La deuxième, c'est que aux États-Unis,
tu peux faire 1000 km ou 1500 km et tu
sors pas du pays. Tandis que nous, tu
fais 1000 km, tu traverses quatre ou
cinq frontières. Donc la société civile
européenne est une société civile qui
est très internationale. Et ça c'est la
différence essentielle tandis que le
système d'internationalisation de des
États-Unis, c'est une intégration dans
l'identité nationale américaine. Ce que
je te raconter sur le chauffeur de taxi
tout à l'heure.
Et le
les États-Unis, par exemple ont 1 % de
musulmans dont la moitié sont
déconvertis. Tu comprends bien que c'est
pas la même caractéristique que la
société française qui a entre 6 et 8 %
de musulmans,
ça fait à peu près 5 à 6 millions de
personnes. Et donc ce n'est pas du tout
le même rapport au monde arabomusulman.
Mais c'est pour ça qu'il faut pas
prendre les analyses américaines parce
qu'elles sont faites dans un monde qui
est complètement différent du n are.
Donc retrouver cette espèce
d'indépendance en se disant nos
fragilités, nos avantages, nos atouts
sont pas les mêmes que ceux des
Américains. Faut-il s'aligner sur ce que
décident les Américains sur le monde
arabusulman ? Faut-il s'aligner sur leur
position très proisraélienne ? On est
aujourd'hui dans une situation où à
Gaza, on doit être je crois 30 morts en
quelques jours là de types qui n'ont pas
franchi la frontière. Ils ont simplement
approché des barbelés. Bon, c'est pas
une situation normale. Le discours de
Trump et de Macron hier a totalement
écarté toute solution du problème
israélo-palestinien.
De même qui n'a absolument pas évoqué le
Yémen, de même qui n'a absolument pas
évoqué l'occupation de Bahrain. Donc on
se dit bah après tout est-ce que notre
président est en train de se mettre lui
aussi dans la ligne américaine ? Je le
pense pas. Je pense que c'est un petit
peu plus intelligent que ça mais ils
avaient beaucoup se disputer avant donc
il s'est dû se dire que la conférence de
presse, il valait mieux afficher une
certaine
proximité sans marqué
proximité.
Euh
le Liban dans tout ça, est-ce que le
Liban va imploser ? Est-ce que le Liban
quand on voit Ari posé avec
le roi d'Arabie Saoudite, le roi du
Maroc, grand sourire,
je sais pas, le Libanais ont une
caractéristique extraordinaire, c'est
que c'est une population qui a été
capable d'absorber toutes les
occupations en restant indépendante. Tu
sais, un libanais, tu te jettes en
l'air, il reste accroché au plafond,
hein. Non, je veux dire, c'est pas
c'est une population qui a été habituée
à vivre, si tu veux, toutes les toutes
les soumissions, toutes les coexistences
et cetera et cetera. Donc moi, si tu
veux, la dernière fois que j'étais au
Liban, j'ai été interviewé par la chaîne
Almanar qui est la chaîne du Esbola.
Il vient de me chercher à à l'hôtel en
la nuit, on fait des tours dans Beout et
cetera. Finalement, on arrive dans une
espèce de quartier obscur devant un mur
de béton et puis avec un type avec une
kalashnikov. Donc, je descends, je fais
l'interview et c'était la le studio
d'Almanar très moderne d'ailleurs que
jamais les Israéliens n'avaient trouvé
pendant l'occupation la dernière
invasion du de Liban. On fait
l'interview donc j'avais dû donner
satisfaction parce que quand je remonte
dans la voiture, on met 5 minutes à
rentrer à l'hôtel. Bon donc si tu veux,
si tu as pas compris ça, c'est-à-dire
que le esbola représente d'une certaine
manière la force libanaise qui a été
capable de stopper de salle. Donc c'est
un des éléments de l'identité nationale
libanaise. Si on fait l'analyse quand on
fait là-bas les Américains et
probablement un certain nombre de
français, c'est le esbola est une
puissance déstabilisatrice du Liban.
Non, c'est une puissance libanaise. Bon,
qui soit chiit est donc proche de
l'Iran. Oui, de même que les chrétiens
maronites, ils sont proches de nous.
Donc, je veux dire, il y a pas de raison
de reprocher aux autres. Ce qui est que
qu'une des composantes de la société
iranienne soit fondamentalement
exclusive si tu veux ou doivent être
exclus du champ politique libanais. Le
cas de Hariri si tu veux, c'était quand
même extraordinaire. C'est-à-dire que tu
avais le fils d'un homme d'affaires qui
a fait fortune en Arabie Saoudite à qui
ces créanciers redemandent une partie de
son pognon. Bon, il s'est tombé sur le
fils et pas sur le père. C'était ça le
problème. Mais finalement le la qualité
extraordinaire de Macron, c'est d'avoir
fait comprendre à Mohamed Ben Salman qui
marchait complètement à côté de ses
pompes quand même. Donc du coup, il a
libéré et tu vois le c'est pour ça qu'il
vaut mieux pas trop se prendre position
dans la situation libanaise puisque tu
vois le même personnage avec le roi
d'Arabie Saoudite et avec le roi du
Maroc. Ensuite boire un coup
probablement il on dit pas ce qu'il y
avait dans les verrs hein mais enfin
probablement boire de l'alcool.
On a une petite question d'internet.
L'Iran vient d'annoncer qu'elle allait
utiliser l'euro plutôt que le dollar
pour ses transactions internationales et
donc et donc le pétrole. Quelles
conséquences pour l'Europe ? Les
conséquences pour les États-Unis ? Bah,
je trouve que c'est une bonne c'est une
bonne décision dans la mesure où
effectivement l'indexation en dollar
donne aujourd'hui beaucoup de moyens de
pression aux Américains. Un des moyens
de pression qui sont les plus mal
connus, ça a été en particulier euh le
procès qui a été fait à stom ou le
procès qui ont été fait à d'autres
entreprises pour avoir simplement
utilisé le dollar comme moyen de
transaction internationale, non ? ce qui
rendait la justice américaine compétente
pour pouvoir juger d'actes de corruption
qui ne s'étaient même pas passé sur le
territoire américain. Donc si tu veux
sortir de cette espèce de monopole du
dollar, c'est un défi hein, je veux dire
c'est c'est un enjeu énorme. Ça veut pas
dire que ça va demain trouver le sa
concrétisation, une espèce de balance,
mais il est sûr qu'on est dans une
situation où les Chinois eux-mêmes
détiennent des bondes du trésor. Donc
ils sont une puissance qui peut
fragiliser les Américains. Vous même
utiliser l'euro, c'est une manière de
stabiliser le cours des monnaies et donc
d'autres pays utilisent l'euros. C'est
plutôt une évolution que je trouve
plutôt positive. Quand tu vois la Chine
se projeter avec ses revendications dans
la mer de Chine avec ce ce plan en neuf
trait, quand on voit Taiïwan se se
préparer à une invasion chinoise, ça ça
augure quoi pour toi là-bas ?
Écoute, le cas chinois est quand même
très intéressant parce que ça fait à peu
près depuis 49 qu'on explique que la
Chine est une menace. Donc c'est une
menace lancente puisque la Chine a fait
en tout deux conflits hein qui étaient
un premier contre l'Inde et un deuxième
contre le Vietnam en 79 alors que l'Inde
pays d'une sais on a fait une bonne
dizaine dont trois contre le Pakistan,
une sur les Sri Lanka et cetera et
cetera. Donc cette construction de
l'image de l'ennemi est une chose à
laquelle moi j'accorde beaucoup
d'importance parce qu'encore une fois
quand les Chinois disent
qui disent justement qu'ils ne sont pas
une puissance
invasive, enfin ils sont une puissance,
ils sont en train de devenir une
puissance militaire mais ils sont pas
une puissance invasive. Bon, donc
tu es obligé de comparer cette
déclaration avec les faits. Donc le fait
de dire attention les Chinois font si
les Chinois font ça, moi je le je juge à
la je juge à la à la pratique. Alors par
exemple la route de la soie, tu sais qui
est maintenant cette grande volonté de
développer tout un flux économique entre
l'Asie et l'Europe et là aussi vu comme
une espèce de démonstration invasive de
des Chinois avec la volonté de maîtriser
la situation. Bon
je te prends un exemple. Le le pétrole
des pays de du golfe s'en va pour
l'essentiel en Asie.
Nous, on s'alimente plutôt avec le golf
de Guinée, avec l'Amérique latine et
cetera. Si demain, il y a des bateaux de
guerre chinois qui rentrent dans le golf
en disant "Nous venons sécuriser nos
voies d'approvisionnement."
Ce qu'ils avaient fait avec le le
collier de perle, non ?
C'est ce qu'ils avaient fait avec le
collier de perle. Mais je veux dire, à
partir une puissance économique, je
viens sécuriser mes voies
d'approvisionnement. Il nous ressortent
l'argument qu'on a utilisé nous pour
toute la colonisation. C'est-à-dire
attention, nous sommes une puissance,
vous ne pouvez pas faire des choses qui
nous seraient défavorables. Bon, donc
est-ce qu'on va considérer que c'est une
menace ou est-ce que va considérer que
c'est une contribution à la sécurité
internationale ? Tu vois que c'est une
question de point de vue. Donc la la
volonté de contrôler la mer de Chine,
oui, mais je veux dire c'est des
conflits territoriaux comme il y en a
plein. Nous aussi, on a eu un problème
avec l'Angleterre sur la mer d'iroise.
La question c'est de savoir s'ils
accepteront la jurisprudence de la Cour
internationale de justice, celle de de
la quoi, celle qui règle les questions
d'état entre tempemps. Moi, je suis
comme moyennement préoccupé par ce genre
de situation parce que évidemment si
c'est celui qui accuse le premier qui a
raison hein.
Revenons au sujet de ton dernier
bouquin.
Ben, mon dernier bouquin est parti d'un
constat que j'évoqué tout à l'heure,
c'est que
comme tous les gens qui sont allés aux
États-Unis, si tu veux, tout le monde
remarque qu'il y a des drapeaux
américains partout sur les barbecue, sur
les voitures, sur les maisons et cetera.
Et donc je me posais cette question,
c'est-à-dire comment est-ce que peut-on
être si fier d'un d'une identité
nationale qui a quand même été
esclavagiste, génocidaire, raciste,
ségrégationniste jusqu'aux années 60 et
impérialiste. Donc je rentre dans une
librairie et je dis au type je voudrais
voir vos manuels d'histoire. Le type me
dit mais il y a pas de manuel d'histoire
pour une raison assez simple, c'est
qu'il y a pas de ministère de
l'éducation nationale.
Ah si, comment peut-on vivre sans le
ministère de l'éducation nationale ? Il
me dit non, c'est de la compétence de
chaque état. Et donc tu imagines que la
guerre de sécession racontée en
Californie, en Caroline du Nord, c'est
pas tout à fait pareil. Et euh il me dit
d'ailleurs moi-même, c'était un type
cultivé, j'ai fait 3 années d' tr années
d'histoire, c'est une année d'histoire
américaine, une année d'histoire du
monde et puis le non deux années
d'histoire, c'est tout. et puis il après
il était passé dans le supérieur. Bon et
donc je me suis dit mais c'est quand
même étonnant puisque nous notre
identité nationale a été faite par le
l'éducation hein, c'est par les grands
programmes 3e République. Euh
or aux États-Unis l'identité nationale a
finalement l'unité nationale était faite
par le cinéma par Hollywood.
C'est-à-dire que Hollywood est le seul à
finalement avoir eu un discours qui a
couvert la totalité du de la
du public américain puisque l'école ne
jouait pas ce rôle.
Donc je me suis amusé à remonter
l'histoire du cinéma en me disant mais
finalement comment est-ce que Hollywood
a construit le discours sur l'identité
américaine par rapport aux autres ?
Et alors
ça m'a d'autant plus fasciné que dans le
cinéma mué,
le premier à être diabolisé, c'est le
noir. Le noir parce que en gros
l'interrogation c'est est-ce que ces
gens-là valaient la peine qu'on se
massacre pour eux ?
Alors ça, il y a un certain nombre de
films mués comme la naissance d'une
nation et cetera qui sont des films
considérés comme les plus racistes des
États-Unis y compris par les Américains,
mais qui reviennent sur l'idée que le
Cuclux Clan est une espèce de protection
défensive contre les comment dire les
carpet baggers, c'est-à-dire les types
qui arrivent du nord pour acheter des
grandes propriétés, des noirs qu'on a
libéré qui veulent se venger et cetera
et cetera. Donc c'est un film raciste
mais il est considéré comme un grand
classique du cinéma américain.
Donc dans ces films noirs si tu veux
qu'on va avoir notre époque du cinéma
bué, les stéréotypes sont très
classiques. Bon, tu as la mama. La mama
c'est elle qui s'occupe des enfants.
Elle est gentille, elle bou comme ça, tu
sais. Il y a la petite fille idiote. Tu
regardes par exemple autant d'emporte
levant. Tu as l'oncle de Tom, tu as de
buck. Le buc, c'est le type qui est le
gros musclé qui veut se taper une
blanche et puis tu as l'abruti qui est
sur le bord du Mississippi et qui joue
du banjo toute la journée. C'est les
stéréotype. Il y a des bouquins très
très documentés sur le sujet. Bon, après
on va passer. Alors, le cinéma n'a
jamais répercuté les luttes sociales des
noirs dans les années 60. Il a fallu que
les noirs se prennent par la main pour
créer ce qu'on appelait la black
exploitation, c'est-à-dire le moment où
le c'est du cinéma noir fait par des
noirs. Après le noir, tu as eu le rouge.
Le rouge, c'est 2700 western.
Comme tu le sais, tu en as peut-être vu
une trentaine ou une quarantaine. 2700.
Non, moi je m'en suis tapé un certain
nombre parce que sur les chaînes comme
Paramount et machin, il y en a un
certain nombre qui sortent en série.
Alors le rouge, ben c'est le sauvage.
D'abord, il est sauvage puisquil à
moitié nu. C'est celui qui refuse la la
civilisation puisqu'il va résister au
colon. Bon, il a une femme de temps en
temps dont on peut montrer les jambes
parce que quand même, rappelle-toi, les
femmes de cowboy, c'est quand même
plutôt la grosse robe avec des la
crryoline et tout ça. C'est le type qui
est cruel et sauvage puisqu'il fait
quand même le scalpe, le poteau de
torture. Et donc ça va être une
légitimité du massacre. Je pense
qu'Hollywood a tué plus d'indiens
d'ailleurs que les guerres indiennes,
hein. Je pense. Mais le retard entre le
western et la réalité historique est
pathétique parce que les Indiens vont
connaître ce qu'on a appelé la la marche
des larmes, c'est-à-dire le moment où
les Américains vont les déplacer
pratiquement sur à peu près 8000 km pour
les mettre dans des dans des réserves en
les faisant marcher à pied. Sur les
13000 ou 14000 Indiens, je crois qu'il y
en a à peu près 6000 qui sont morts en
route.
Hollywood a mis 20 a mis le premier film
sur la marge des la marge des larmes se
fait dans les années 60. Or, tu vois les
2700 western dont je parle c'est entre
30 et 54 à peu près. Bon donc le rouge.
Après ça on passe au jaune. Alors le
jaune c'est l'époque docteur Fumanchou.
C'est l'arrivée des Chinois
pour construire le la transpacifique.
Et donc le le chinois docteur Fumanchu,
c'est le mec cruel qui passe son temps à
faire des tortures et qui est
particulièrement perfide. Alors je
reviens quand même là-dessus. Le héros
du film, il est toujours joué par un
blanc grimé he de temps en temps, il est
peint en rouge, en temps il est peint en
jaune, mais c'est toujours un acteur
bable qui doit donc ça va être
Christopher lui qui va jouer une
6 ou se des 13 versions de de
Fumanchu.
Alors le jeune c'est l'avantage c'est
que c'est une catégorie générique
c'està-dire il est chinois au départ
ensuite il va devenir japonais pendant
la guerre ensuite il va devenir coréen
après-guerre puis ensuite il va devenir
redevenir chinois si tu veux ou il va
devenir vietnamien ensuite il va devenir
chinois bon donc c'est l'avantage c'est
que au moins tu peux utiliser les mêm
les mêmes acteurs. D'ailleurs, les
acteurs chinois qui arrivaient pas à
trouver de boulot avant guerre vont
devenir tout à coup des Japonais puisque
finalement là, on a besoin de Chinois
qu'on va pas utiliser des Japonais
américains pu ceuxl ils sont dans les
camps. Bon donc ils vont devenir tout à
coup les soldats
une parenthèse explique à nos auditeurs
les camps de rétention administratifs de
l'époque.
Bah si tu veux il s'est passé que dès
qu'il y a eu l'attaque de Perbourg qui a
quand même été une attaque qui a
traumatisé considérablement les
Américains puisque c'est une attaque
sans déclaration de guerre et cetera.
Donc, il y a eu tout un mouvement de
réaction euh d'arrestation de Japonais
américains en pensant qu'ils étaient des
traîtres en puissance, des esprits en
puissance. Donc, on les met dans des
camps de de détention
avec effectivement une où ils vont
rester pratiquement toute la guerre.
Moi, je reste sur le plan d'Hollywood si
tu veux. Il fallait du jaune. Donc, le
jaune, on a pris les Chinois. Donc,
c'était quand même une époque où il y
avait un racisme antijaponais très
virulent. Il y a des photos de
travailleurs chinois qui avaient sur le
dos I am not [__] I am Chinese.
C'està-dire que le type était obligé de
préciser qu'ils étaient chinois.
Je te coupe
et je je recentre dans notre époque. H
Est-ce que nous en Europe, on est en
train de faire la même chose avec nos
migrants ?
Non, je crois pas. Je crois pas. Je
crois pas parce que si tu veux le
notre rapport enfin la la fonction de
Hollywood a été de construire une grande
mythologie nationale. Je reviens à mon
point de départ. Donc euh le postulat,
c'est que vous êtes dans la meilleure
société du monde. Donc l'autre ne peut
être qu'un envieu, un jaloux ou un
ennemi. Bon et donc si tu fais la
succession, c'est-à-dire qu'après le
noir, le rouge, le jaune, euh tu as le
basané, pas l'oublier quand même, le
mexicain. Euh, ensuite tu as le blanc
euh qui va être le le film d'espionnage
et puis maintenant, tu es dans l'araboir
terroristomulman. Bon, donc si tu veux,
tu as un continuum de la production
idéologique hollywoodienne qui est très
caractéristique et on a rien
d'équivalent. On a rien. Notre premier
film si tu veux sur le la guerre
d'Algérie par exemple se fait 20 ans
après la fin de la guerre d'Algérie.
C'est Avoir 20 ans dans les
qui est un film qui reconnaît la
légitimité de la guerre d'indépendance
algérienne.
Le premier film sur les premiers films
critiques sur la guerre du Vietnam, que
ce soit Hamburger Hill, que ce soit
enfin t tous les films qu'on a tous vu
sur le Vietnam
sont tous centrés sur la souffrance du
soldat américain. Il n'y a jamais un
vietnamien positif dans ces films.
C'est-à-dire que la différence
idéologique entre tout ça, c'est que on
fait le fonction d'autocritique
vis-à-vis de l'autre ce que les
Américains ne font pas. Ils sont
d'autant plus critiques vis-à-vis de
leur situation intérieure. Alors là,
c'est une liberté totale de critique.
Mais dès que ça touche à l'autre, il y a
un espèce de barrage idéologique.
Revenons à nos migrants. Les flux
miratoires en Europe.
Oui.
Tu anticipes ça comment ?
Bah écoute, on est dans une situation où
le
si tu te mets de la du côté du position
du politique,
le politique, il est coincé entre deux
fonctions. Le droit d'asile qui est un
droit de protection des gens qui sont
massacrés pour leur sexe, leur culture,
leur et cetera. Et puis le flux
économique. Bon, le flux économique, ça
de ce côté-là, le président était très
clair. C'està-dire on peut pas
aujourd'hui accepter toute migrant au
contexte qu'il est effectivement dans
une situation de pauvreté.
La difficulté c'est effectivement de de
d'appliquer le pardon de les stopper
déjà.
Bah d'abord c'est la question c'est de
les stopper.
Est-ce qu'on va construire le mur ?
C'est pas sûr qu'on recherche le mur
prudent, mais on est plutôt dans une
négociation pour euh
gérer si tu veux le le dans les pays qui
sont au contact des départs.
Tu remarques la remarque la remarquable
porte d'entrée que constitue la Libye
qui grâce à BHL est aujourd'hui un état
en pleine décomposition et donc
aujourd'hui les flux d'entrée se passent
par ces régions-là qui sont aujourd'hui
des pays sans état où notre bonne
volonté était là pour protéger les
populations. Tu te souviens de savoir ?
Donc on a aujourd'hui ouvert un certain
nombre de portes. On a effectivement
négocié avec la Turquie pour qu'une
partie de ces ces réfugiés se passe dans
ces étatsl. Je fais une petite attends
je fais une petite incidente.
Les jour aujourd'hui les pays les plus
vides et les plus riches sont ceux qui
accueillent aucun pays. Aucun migrant.
Ce sont les pays du golf. Les pays du
golf n'accueillent aucun migrant.
Pour une raison assez simple, c'est
qu'ils n'ont jamais signé les
conventions internationales sur les
réfugiés. pour une raison assez simple,
c'est qu'ils veulent pas prendre des
chiites, ils veulent pas prendre des
nonmusulmans, ils veulent prendre que
des sunnites. Et donc aujourd'hui, le
mur dont tu parle, il est construit au
nord de l'Arabie Saoudite. Il est plus
long que le mur israélien sur les
territoires occupés et il est destiné
essentiellement à empêcher les migrants
d'entrer dans les pays du golfe. Donc je
m'étonne un peu si tu veux qu'on se
qu'on se flagelle nous-même en disant
"Non là, regardez ce qu'on fait et
cetera." Au lieu d'aller poser le
problème sur la table des pays de la
région qui ont des moyens, de l'argent
et de l'espace et sans jamais leur faire
une moindre remord. Bon, l'Arabie
Saoudite, c'est pas la densité de la
Hollande quand même. Bon, donc on
pourrait très bien si tu veux avoir une
posture diplomatique mais qui encore une
fois ne veut pas vexer tous ces pays qui
sont parmi nos bons clients. Donc on est
dans cette situation étonnante où moi je
suis assez distancié si tu veux sur la
la critique de notre posture. Bien sûr
que c'est un drame humain. Bien sûr
qu'il faut les accueillir dans les
formes les plus dignes possibles. Mais
il reste le problème politique, c'est
qu'on n'est pas dans une situation où on
peut accueillir du flux économique de de
migrants cherchant du travail parce que
on n'est pas dans une situation où on
peut pas expliquer à des chômeurs
français que notre générosité va jusque
là. Et sur la question du droit d'asile,
on revient sur un problème important qui
est celui qu'on a connu avec les
attentats terroristes. C'est
qu'aujourd'hui le droit d'asile était le
droit d'asile était conçu dans les
années 50 signé des grandes conventions
internationales parce que tous les pays
occidentaux avaient refusé les juifs à
patrine que chasser Hitler. Donc après
guerre, on a fait notre autocritique et
donc on a signé des grandes conventions
sur la protection des réfugiés
persécutés pour des régions de sexe,
pour des régions de religion, pour des
mois.
Et donc tu ne peux pas refuser un
réfugié s'il présente ces
caractéristiques là. Bon c'est la raison
pour lesquelles les pays du golf n'ont
jamais signé ces convention. Mais
aujourd'hui on on l'a vu avec l'exemple
de Londonistan. Si on accueille un
réfugié uniquement parce que dans son
pays il est persécuté pour des raisons
qui peuvent être éventuellement des
actes terroristes. C'est-à-dire que
quand tu combines ça avec la
jurisprudence de la Cour européenne, on
dit on peut pas l'expulser parce qu'il
risque d'être torturé chez lui ou
condamné à mort. Ça a été la
constitution du Londonistan. Londonistan
étant un foyer salafiste en plein milieu
de Londres. Moi, je me souviens d'avoir
assisté à des prêches de de Salafis de
de
la mosquée de Dchley Park où c'était
d'un racisme, d'une antisémitisme, une
violence extraordinaire. Tu avais un
bobi qui tournait autour tranquillement,
les mains dans le dos et cetera. Toute
chose que nous on aurait très bien pu
refuser si tu veux parce qu'on a des
lois sur la liberté de parole. Le
résultat de tout ça, ça a été
Londonistan et tout à coup quand il y a
eu les attentats de Londres en 2005 ciel
les Anglais sont se sont réveillés en
disant "Mais comment se fait-il que des
gens puisse vivre en Angleterre et que
la nationalité anglaise sans jamais
parler un mot d'anglais ?" Donc le
réexamen de la politique de droit
d'asile, c'est de dire aujourd'hui comme
on l'avait dit à l'époque des réfuses
niques, le droit d'asile est réservé à
des gens qui sont des défenseurs des
libertés. Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
Or, tu prends des exemples de trous dans
notre dispositif où tu as des quartiers
salafhisés qui sont constitués à partir
de réfugiés.
auquel on offre si tu veux le droit
d'asile alors que mon avis il y aurait
pas droit. Donc si tu veux, on est dans
pleine époque d'un réexamen à la fois de
ce concept de droit d'asile et celui
évidemment des migrants pour lequel de
fait c'est la loi qui a été proposée par
le gouvernement, c'est-à-dire encore une
fois tous les migrants n'ont pas
automatiquement le droit à être sur le
territoire foncé.
Revenons à Hollywood Hollywir. Hm
hm.
Comment ça va se déployer sur les
populations européennes ? Comment ça
s'est déjà déployé
? Tu parles de quoi ? de bah si tu veux
le le cinéma a donc été quand même un
des éléments les plus efficaces du soft
power américain.
Rappelle-toi que dans les l'immédiate
après-guerre,
un des éléments de la négociation, Bloom
va qui est redevenu premier ministre va
chercher une aide exceptionnelle aux
États-Unis et dans la négociation
d'ensemble, Hollywood va essayer
d'imposer ce qu'on appelle le plan
Bloomburns, c'est-à-dire l'ouverture des
salles européennes au cinéma américain.
Et donc à ce moment-là va commencer une
grande un succès d'autant plus grand que
tout le cinéma européen parle de drame
de la guerre, de l'occupation, de la
résistance et cetera. Alors que le
cinéma rééricain arrive avec du happy
end, avec des tas de films où tout le
monde est content, où c'est enthousiaste
et cetera, des films où tu as des héros
positifs. Bon donc tout ça va être un
énorme succès qui va largement
contribuer à
à ce succès du cinéma américain. Et pour
en mesurer l'efficacité, je fournis dans
le livre un sondage assez extraordinaire
qui a été fait en quatre épisodes,
c'est-à-dire en 45, en 60, 70 et puis
jusqu'à 2000.
Et la question est toujours la même,
c'est-à-dire selon vous, qui a été le
pays qui a le plus contribué à la
victoire de 45 ? Donc en 45, c'est
l'URSS à 60 %. Et puis au fur et à
mesure, pendant la guerre foi, tu vas
voir que le rôle de les de la Russie va
diminuer puis le rôle des États-Unis va
croître. Et la même question posée en
1990 ou en 2000, c'est les Américains
qui ont le plus contribué à la victoire.
On est sur quelque chose qui est un fait
objectif.
Tu sais que les Américains sur les
Américains sur l'ensemble des théâtres
ont perdu autant de monde que la Russie
dans la seule bataille de Stalingrad.
Donc c'est difficile de de sortir de cet
épisode mais tu vois comment se façonne
une idéologie collective. Et donc
aujourd'hui, tu as effectivement une
machine qui a une très forte capacité
d'influence et en sens contraire les
Américains sont très fermés à l'arrivée
de cinéma européen. Ils achètent un film
et ils l'américanisent. Par exemple,
Nikita, c'est devenu nom de corde Nina.
Tu as les mêmes séquences plan, les
mêmes découpages et cetera, mais le tout
avec des acteurs américains. Et le le
côté le plus cocass, c'est le film La
marche de l'empereur parce que c'était
en fait un documentaire avec une voix
off et à partir du moment où comme ça a
été un succès mondial et qu'il a été
acheté aux États-Unis, la voix off est
devenue une voix américaine. Donc tout
le monde est aux États-Unis convaincu
que c'est un film américain. C'est que
les pingouins, ils ont pas de
nationalité. Ça connaîre. ce format de
l'opinion publique depuis des décennies,
est-ce que
ça va comment te poser la question ?
Est-ce qu'on on n pas abruti les gens
tellement profondément qu'ils n'ont plus
la capacité à comprendre les rouages et
les racines de l'histoire et ce qui nous
projette dans le futur ? Est-ce qu'ils
sont devenus malléables
par un pouvoir politique qui a besoin de
ça ?
Moi je sais pas, il faut reconnaître que
les les élections ça un avantage, c'est
ça crée des surprises. Donc je suis pas
sûr que si tu veux la la le formatage de
l'opinion publique soit un fait avéré
pour beaucoup de raisons parce que on
est tous composés de multiples variables
si tu veux qui font qu'à un certain
moment on va voter d'un côté, d'un autre
côté, qu'on va trouver le nom politique
une qualité ou une autre et cetera et
cetera. Donc je suis pas convaincu que
les gouvernants puissent faire aux
population exactement toujours ce qu'ils
ont envie.
Il y a des moyens de soft power, ça
c'est vrai, sur les relations
internationales.
C'est sûr que par exemple, on le voyait
bien à l'époque de l'Union soviétique,
la propagande a été inventée quand même
au 20e siècle, hein.
La propagande, c'est de la publicité
politique et la publicité, c'est de la
propagande commerciale. Donc, on avait
les mêmes techniques, si tu veux pour
arriver à convaincre une opinion, soit
d'acheter un produit, soit d'acheter un
dirigeant. Ça marchait dans certains
cas, ça marchait pas dans d'autres. Donc
heureusement, c'est pas une science
exacte la propagande.
On conseille d'ailleurs le bouquin
propaganda.
H
question d'internet, rôle des jeux
vidéos, point d'interrogation des jeux
vidéos américains. Call of Duty,
Battlefield, ça te parle pas ?
Ça me parle pas, je fais pas de jeux
vidéo.
Ça remonte à quand la dernière fois que
tu as touché une manette ?
J'en ai jamais touché une. Je joue pas
aux jeux vidéos.
Est-ce que tu vois à peu près à quoi ça
sert ?
Non, non, je sais pas. Non, non. On peut
prendre l'exemple des séries américaines
si tu veux parce que c'est beaucoup plus
rigolo. Les séries donc sont une
nouvelle production hollywoodienne dont
tu connais la logique. C'est-à-dire
qu'il y a un épisode dans lequel on pose
une problématique mais qui enchaîne tout
de suite sur une seconde problématique
qui va te renvoyer à l'épisode suivant
qui lui-même va te empoiser à moi. Et
donc ces séries-là, moi c'est le contenu
idéologique de ces séries qui m'amusent.
Et donc j'en prends par exemple une qui
est Homelande. Homeland donc si tu
connais cette histoire, c'est le soldat
américain qui a été emprisonné par les
talibans qui va être libéré qui donc va
être accueilli comme héros national aux
États-Unis. Bon et en fait, on va
découvrir au fur et à mesure de
l'avancée du scénario que le type est en
fait converti, qu'il a lui-même
contribué à torturer ses camarades de
emprisonné et puis que en fait il
prépare un attentat terroriste. Mais là
où c'est rigolo, c'est que à un moment
les producteurs voulaient tourner un une
série un épisode qui devait se passer en
Syrie. Évidemment, il était pas question
d'aller en Syrie. Donc il le tourne en
Afrique du Sud, ce qui est normal
puisque c'est le pays le plus proche.
Tu parles des fameux tags.
Ah ouais. Alors justement le donc le il
recrute des des musulmans locaux et donc
à qui on demande de jouer le le rôle des
méchants, des terroristes et cetera et
puis en plus le type cita un peu parce
qu'ils en a un peu marre donc on les
sollicite toujours pour jouer les
méchants. Et donc on leur demande en
plus de faire des tags sur les murs pour
montrer à bas l'impérialisme, à bas le
sionisme et cetera et donc les types
s'exécutent.
Et ça a été un immense éclat quand le
film est passé dans les pays arabes
parce que tout à coup en fait ils
avaient écrit "Ne regardez pas cette
série, cette série raciste, ça ne
traduit pas le la volonté des des
acteurs et cetera parce qu'il y avait
personne dans l'équipe qui parlait
l'arabe. Donc la construction de
l'ennemi, c'était une construction
spécifiquement hollywoodienne qui devait
répondre à un scénario et donc il y en a
plein d'autres comme ça.
Est-ce que tu connais la série Black
Mirror ?
Black
Black Mirror ?
Non, je crois pas. On te on te la
recommande. Euh, autre question
d'internet qui est en train de s'écrire.
Est-ce qu'il y a un renouveau de cette
propagande avec les super-héros
américain genre Marvel, des choses comme
ça ?
Alors, ça c'est une caractéristique du
cinéma américain, c'est-à-dire que le
personnage central de la production
hollywoodienne, c'est le héros
Jacksonia. Pourquoi on assise sur le
Jacksonia ? Parce que Jackson est le 5e
président des États-Unis, je crois, qui
le premier à contester le pouvoir que
monopolis les élites de la côte est. Bon
et donc par c'est devenu une tradition
dans la culture américaine, le héros
jacksonien c'est l'individu contre le
système. Bon et donc tu vas
régulièrement avoir ça. C'est-à-dire que
tu vas avoir le cowboy qui va être
éventuellement contre
euh l'indépendance si tu veux qui va
faire la justice lui-même. Euh tu vas
avoir le soldat qui se heurte à sa
hiérarchie mais qui finalement va avoir
raison et cetera et cetera. Donc le film
est centré sur un héros positif qui
évidemment est américain et qui va donc
traverser si tu veux le truc. Alors le
héros va changer de forme parce que au
début dans le dans le western, bon ben
le héros il fait mouche avec une pétoire
du 19e siècle à 50 pas comme tu le sais.
Par contre aujourd'hui, quand tu as des
échanges de coups de feu, notamment avec
des armes à répétition, bah ils se
tirent dessus pendant 10 minutes avant
d'arriver à se toucher. Donc je sais
pas, il faut croire que ils ont ils sont
devenus miop avec le temps. Mais par
contre, le héros va avoir des capacités
de plus en plus grandes. Euh donc tu vas
avoir le super combattant, enfin le
combattant qui va être essentiellement
cristallisé par Chuck Norris, machin
Stallon, Vin Diesel et cetera et cetera.
Donc celui-là c'est le combattant
normal. Combattant normal. Alors, il
arrive en général équipé comme un
croiseur de comme un croiseur de
bataille. C'est-à-dire que tu vois bien
que Stalon, il lui faut évidemment une
bande de 127 autour du coup et puis
autour de la poitrine parce qu'il est
toujours en tricot marcel, je sais pas
pourquoi mais enfin, il est toujours en
tricotomel et donc il a une mitraillette
dans chaque main et il tire avec les
deux mains. Bon euh alors quand les
Américains représentent la guerre, tu as
une contradiction entre les contraintes
du cinéma et les contraintes de la
guerre. Dans la guerre, ce que dit Close
Vitz, c'est ce qu'on appelle le
brouillard de la guerre. C'est-à-dire
quand close vit
Carl von Close Vit
euh c'est-à-dire que quand tu es
combattant, ben le moindre des choses,
c'est que tu essayes de pas te faire
butter, donc tu essayes de te cacher,
donc tu essayes de savoir où sont tes
amis, où sont tes ennemis. Bon, dans le
cinéma américain, tu peux pas faire
coucher. Tu
On va peut-être aller voir notre ami le
voisin qui nous fait une petite danse
là.
On va attendre qu'il arrête.
Attends, c'est juste au-dessus. Qui
c'est qui s'en occupe ? Attends, bouge
pas. Ça a l'air de se calmer. Donc dans
le cinéma, tu veux pas faire coucher ce
talon par terre en pensant qu'il faut
qu'il évite les balles. Donc il va se
dresser fièrement avec une mitraillette
dans chaque main en tirant et en faisant
mouche à chaque fois autour de ses
ennemis qui vont se disperser autour de
lui. Bon alors on est dans la transition
du héros au super-héros. Alors
superhéros, ça veut dire que par exemple
dans Rambo 2,
le le Rambo 1 est très intéressant.
C'est l'ancien combattant qui rentre au
pays et qui effectivement se heurte à
une société qui veut plus le voir. Bon,
comme on le vexe, il détruit un village
mais enfin sans vouloir vraiment le
faire exprès. Tu as remarqué que quand
il quitte le village, il y a plus rien
de bout hein. Bon Rambo 2, il va on va
le rappeler pour qu'il retourne au
Vietnam et là tout à coup il est
redevenu le combattant et il dit
d'ailleurs cette fois on y va pour
gagner. Thèse classique de l'extrême
droite. Si on a perdu la guerre, c'est
la faute des bureaucrates et des
politiciens. Et dans le Rambo 2, il
tuent 76 personnes. Je les ai compté.
Bon, tu imagines qu'on fasse un film
comme ça sur les l'Algérie avec un
ancien combattant d'Algérie retournant
en Algérie, tu as 76 Algériens, ça
ferait un scandale politique
gigantesque. Ça ne le fait pas euh dans
le système américain. Alors, comme les
Américains ont une distance critique
assez forte, si tu veux, ils ont créé
une base de données dans lesquelles il
donnent chaque année un prix au film le
plus meurtrier de l'année. Donc, il
compte le nombre de morts, il dit "Cette
année, le film qui a tué le plus de
monde, c'est celui-là et cetera." Parce
que ils sont eux même pas dup de ce
truc. C'està-dire, tu as effectivement
aux États-Unis, comme dans toutes les
sociétés, des gens qui sont pas dupes de
cette espèce de discours. Et donc après
le superhéros solitaire, alors quand tu
as pas assez de budget, tu mets de Choc
Norris parce que il moins payé donc il
peut tuer un peu moins de monde. Enfin
donc ça mobilise moins de figurant. Bon
mais le processus même il retourne au
Vietnam aussi et donc il va libérer lui
aussi des prisonniers Vietnam. Et puis
progressivement, on est donc passé au la
catégorie du des super-héros en bande
avec Expandable et autres où tu as quand
même des vétérans, les mecs ont le moyen
d'âge de 60 ans, 65 ans quand même, mais
ils vont effectivement tous ensemble
aller faire le le la police de la
planète. Alors dans je sais plus quel
numéro, je crois que c'est dans
Expendable 2, ça commence au Népal où on
sait pas un groupe d'idents qu' dont on
connaît pas l'identité enlever
Schwarzenegger. Bon quand même c'est une
connerie, je veux dire, ils auraient dû
prendre n'importe quel américain, ils
ont pris Charzard, donc ils vont aller
le libérer. Alors Charzar est torturé,
il lui fait la torture de la piscine.
C'est quand même scandaleux. Bon, c'est
ce qu'on fait les Américains à
Guantanamo, mais on n'est pas sur ce
sujet-là.
Waterboarding. Ouais,
le Oui, le waterboarding. Donc, ils vont
libérer leurs copains Chineger puis
ensuite ils repartent. Alors, je sais
plus où ils vont dans un autre truc en
Bulgarie, libéré des femmes et des
enfants. Et puis il termine dans un pays
qui s'appelle l'Asménistan,
truc tu vois, qui est intermédiaire
entre l'Azerbédistan et Jmenistan dans
laquelle l'armée est totalement
corrompue. C'est comme ça qu'il le
décrivent. Et donc dans la bataille
finale, ils détruisent une dizaine de
chars tous les hélicoptères de l'armée
et cetera. Donc c'est tout ça avec une
bande de vétérans, ce qui prouve quand
même que la capacité combative des
Américains tient à la distance avec
l'âge. Donc on est sur un système où la
guerre est représentée comme une espèce
de jeu de théâtre justement comme un jeu
vidéo et dans lequel évidemment il y a
jamais un truc blessé dans dans Rambo 2
si quand même il se coupe la main parce
qu'il faut que l'héroïne le soigne
est-ce que
mais comme l'héroïne attends je comme
l'héroïne est une rasienne si tu veux il
faut pas qu'elle rentre au pays donc
elle mourra avant la fin parce que la
superhéros peut pas se marier je veux
dire sinon c'est la fin du monde
surtout avec une sauvage c'est pas
possible donc
est-ce que cette théâtralisation de des
des théâtres d'opération et de ce que ce
que ce qu'est réellement la guerre n'a
pas anesthésié les populations
occidentales civilisées face
à la réalité de de notre monde.
C'est-à-dire qu'on a un monde en guerre
avec des vrais morts, avec des gens qui
s'ouvrent
et qui font manger le foie par des
terroristes. Parce que la sceptisation
de ces images et la la théâtralisation
de ces images empêche les populations
occidentales d'avoir un esprit critique
face à des leaders de plus en plus
béliqueux et de plus en plus
arrangé avec arrangeant avec la réalité.
C'est incontestablement vrai pour le
public américain parce que encore une
fois le si tu veux aux États-Unis, tu as
plus de morts par arme à feu pendant
tout le 20e siècle, il y a eu plus de
morts par arme à feu qu'il n'y a eu une
mort dans les gares. Donc ça veut dire
si tu prends la violence par sa
dangérosité, tu comprends bien que la
guerre a été un phénomène qui a mobilisé
mais qui a mobilisé de manière très
superficielle et qui surtout a créé
beaucoup moins de mort que ce qu'on
imagine. Mais par contre, la
théâtralisation du cinéma a fait
qu'effectivement tout apparaît comme une
espèce d'épopée qu'elle se passe au
Pacifique ou qu'elle se passe en Europe.
À chaque fois un discours très
très glorieux si tu veux, très
valorisant et cetera et donc tout ça est
expliqué est effectivement alors ensuite
il y a eu l'épisode du Vietnam qui a été
beaucoup plus douloureux parce que là il
y a eu mobilisation, il y avait donc des
appelés du contingent et cetera. Tiens,
c'est bizarre, Stalon n'a jamais fait la
guerre du Vietnam mais
euh bon je sais pas, je sais pas ce qui
s'est passé. Faudra qu'on revérifie.
Donc si tu veux cette guerre là
effectivement a marqué la société
américaine parce que c'était les boys,
les types devaient y aller et cetera et
cetera. Mais pour le reste toute la
médiatisation de la guerre qui ne s'est
jamais passé sur le territoire
évidemment n'a pas laissé les mêmes
traces que ce que tu imagines en
Allemagne même aujourd'hui. Si
l'Allemagne encore discute pendant des
heures et des heures avant de décider de
participer à une opération
internationale, c'est parce qu'il y a
tout se passé si tu veux qui est
extrêmement important.
Et nous-même la guerre, on l'a connu
jusqu'aux années 62 avec la guerre
d'Algérie quand même. Et puis ensuite,
il y a eu toutes les interventions
extérieures. Bon, donc le rapport à la
guerre est assez différent. Il est assez
différent et surtout il y a pas en
Europe cette valorisation du héros qui
si tu veux dans le les brefs de
comptoir, il y avait un type qui disait
"J'aime bien les films de guerre qui
surtout s'il se terminent bien." C'est
ça Hollywood. Film de guerre doit se
terminer bien. Nous c'est pas évident du
tout.
Toutes les guerres américaines se sont
mal terminées pratiquement. Non
non non non. Il y a eu des guerres qui
sont très bien terminées. La guerre de
14, la participation a été assez limitée
dans le temps et cetera. Mais enfin, ils
sont dans le camp des vainqueurs. La
guerre de 40, ils sont évidemment dans
le camp la guerre de 45, ils sont dans
le camp des vainqueurs. Après, ça
devient plus difficile. La Corée, c'est
un match nul.
Le Vietnam, c'est quasiment un désastre
mais c'est encore des fois, c'est des
guerres dans lesquelles c'est pas une
issue militaire, c'est l'issue politique
si tu veux. Irqu.
Alors après, il y a effectivement cette
ces espèces d'interventions récentes
qui se sont faites notamment en Irak, en
Afghanistan et cetera qui elle tourne
effectivement à la catastrophe. Elle
tourne à la catastrophe parce qu'encore
c'est pas une guerre, c'est une espèce
de décision unilatérale en disant c'est
un pays
13000 km des États-Unis à qui on va
déclarer la guerre. Tu avais des
bombardiers qui partaient de Floride qui
traversaient l'Atlantique qui étaient
dirigé depuis Tampa au Texas pour aller
bombarder des cibles en Afghanistan. Je
dire c'est une forme de guerre assez
particulière. Donc même si tu prends un
film comme American Sniper par exemple
qui est sur le sur le cas de la guerre
en Irak,
Clintastwood non plus a pas fait la
guerre tiens, je sais pas pourquoi. Il
était trop jeune pour la guerre de 45 et
il était trop vieux pour la guerre du
Vietnam. Donc le American Sniper, c'est
l'exemple même de la construction d'un
héros dans lequel on prend un individu
qui a existé qui s'appelait Chris Kyle
qui était un sniper. Un sniper, ça veut
dire que c'est un type qui est installé
en haut des Champsélysées. Tu quelqu'un
qui est en bas des Champsélysées à peu
près hein pour te donner l'idée de la
distance. Donc c'est un type qui fait
pas la guerre. C'est pas un type qui
enfonce une bayonnette dans le ventre
d'un ennemi. Donc ce type qui soit pas
traumatisé, alors il a été traumatisé
parce que je crois qu'il a revendiqué
250 morts côté amé côté iakien mais en
fait ils en ont reconnu que 165. Donc il
y a une profonde injustice. Ce type
retourne quatre fois en Irak. Quatre
fois en Irak. Ça veut dire qu'il
s'emmerde chez lui quand même parce
qu'il a une femme, il a des enfants.
Mais comme on le dit dans le film, comme
on le dit dans le film en fait sa
famille peut attendre tandis que le pays
non. N'oublie pas ce discours important.
Et donc ce type donc Clintwood fait un
film qui est une espèce d'héroïation de
ce personnage
dont la partie la plus intéressante
n'est pas traitée dans le film.
C'est-à-dire qu'une fois qu'il rentre
définitivement d'Irak, donc il va
s'occuper d'autres combattants
américains qui eux souffrent du syndrome
post-traumatique. Le syndrome
post-traumatique, c'est le syndrome des
combattants qui ont connu la guerre et
qui ne rentrre pas entier de leur de
cette guerre. Et il va s'en occuper en
les semmenant dans des stands de tir. Et
puis il y en a un qui devait
probablement en avoir remarque de que
d'entendre Chriscal raconter sa version
de la guerre, c'est-à-dire cette guerre
que je t'ai je t'ai expliqué. Ben, il
lui a il l'a tué. il a tué dans le
centre de tir. C'est-à-dire que toute
cette partie là qui est quand même la
confrontation entre le mec qui a connu
le choc des combats et celui qui ne l'a
pas connu n'est pas traité dans le film.
Bon, je sais pas, je sais pas pourquoi
ça a été oublié.
Est-ce que tu trouves que les
journalistes refont remonter
suffisamment le ce fameux choc des
combats auprès de la population ?
Ben d'abord, c'est pas leur fonction.
Ils essayent de le faire mais ils sont
pas toujours en première ligne, hein.
C'est pas le c'est pas leur vocation.
Ils essayent aussi fréquemment de le
faire et ils sont souvent plus
euh comment dire ? Je crois qu'ils
essayent si tu veux d'être assez
objectif, aussi objectif que possible.
La question c'est encore une fois c'est
que tu peux pas vivre la guerre. Tu peux
pas vivre la guerre du côté de Daesh.
Jamais Daesh n'a accepté qu'un journal.
Sil y en a eu un qui a été un type qui a
fait qui a couvert la guerre du côté de
Daesh
qui est un anglais mais qui a participé
plus à des films de propagande qu'à de
la réalité. C'est-à-dire que chacun
chacune des propagandes se confrontait
et effectivement Daesh a d'ailleurs très
bien conçu sa propre propagande puisque
il ils ont été capables de produire des
films qui reprenaient les codes
américains d'ailleurs pour les retourner
pour mobiliser pour recruter des jeunes
qui justement avaient été formés dans
ces jeux vidéos et dans cette production
cinématographique où cette fois le héros
n'était plus l'américain mais c'était au
contraire le musulman radical. Donc il y
a eu effectivement les journalistes sont
pris au milieu de tout ça, c'est-à-dire
qu'ils sont pris par deux propagandes
différentes et ils essay en tout cas
pour la plupart d'entre eux de garder la
tête hors de l'eau.
On en est où avec le le risque
terroriste en France ?
Ben le risque terroriste, il a changé de
nature puisque euh
c'est devenu euh on est passé d'un
terrorisme exogène organisé, piloté,
structuré et cetera qui s'est manifesté
pour l'essentiel au moment des attentats
de novembre 2016 au Bataclan et cetera à
un terrorisme endogène. Terrorisme
endogène aussi bien sur le plan
organisationnel que sur le plan
financier.
C'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui, il y a
effectivement en France un certain
nombre de quartiers salafisés
dont il est remarquable de constat
pardon
des exemples
ben trappe le M Strasbourg Toulouse le
Mirail Butchumon enfin je veux dire il y
a toute une liste
Nim Nî un peu non
pardon
Nim
alors Nî sais pas parce que si tu veux
dans les attentats qui se sont passés
récemment on était justement à Carcasson
là dans une espèce de triangle où tu
avais Artigat Olivier Corel en Ardèche
tu avais Lunel nous sont partis une
vingtaine de mecs et Puis tu as le
Toulouse le Mirail. Donc lequel a fourni
le plus de coups de main ? Je sais pas.
Mais ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'à
chaque fois qu'il y a eu attentat
terroriste, il y a toujours eu soutien
logistique de ses cellules mais en
restant dans la légalité. C'est-à-dire
ah oui, il avait besoin d'une voiture,
j'ai prêté ma voiture, je l'ai fait
dormir parce que je connais bien sa
mère, tu vois ce genre de truc.
Or, ça c'est le véritable danger puisque
ça veut dire qu'il reste un terau
salafisé en France qui est toujours prêt
à se mobiliser encore une fois en
restant dans la légalité puisque c'est
ça la forme avec le type qui va décider
de passer à l'acte.
Mais pour te donner un exemple, on
commence à parler du salafisme après les
attentats de Charlie Hebdo pour la
première fois. Donc je reviens sur cette
espèce de sanctuarisation de l'Arabie
Saoudite. C'est la première fois en
janvier 2015 qu'un premier ministre Vals
en l'occurrence parle de du salafisme
comme ennemi. Avant on disait l'islam
radical, les musulmans intégristes et
cetera. C'estàd qu'on les mettait tous
dans le même sac pour pas vexer Riad.
En janvier 2015, on commence à parler du
salafisme. Mais entre, je crois qu'entre
2011 et 2018, on a réussi à
je crois que c'est 2011, je me souviens
plus très bien ou 2013, on a réussi à
expulser 35 personnes.
Comme tu vois, c'est une politique d'une
grande efficacité.
L'actuel imam de Marseille là qu'on est
en train d'expulser, il a fallu 9 mois
pour l'expulser. Or, ce type tenait un
discours raciste, homophobe, misogyne,
sectaire, tout ce que tu veux, mais
pareil ont refusé d'intervenir.
Donc tant qu'on ne démantelle pas ces
cellules dormandes qui sont sur le
territoire français, il y a toujours un
terau qui permettra un individu qui a le
coup de
Comment on fait pour démonter ?
Bah, je pense que si tu veux, il y a
plusieurs techniques.
Si tu regardes le stock des fichiers S,
il n'a cessé de grossir. Bon, alors
est-ce que c'est parce qu'on en mesure
mieux la dangérosité ? Parce que bon,
peu importe, ce qui est certain qu'on
peut pas augmenter les moyens des
services de police et de renseignement à
l'infini. Bon, donc tu as deux
solutions. Soit tu augmentes les
services mais ça c'est pas possible.
Soit tu réduis le stock. Réduire le
stock c'est une manière très simple.
C'est tous les individus qui sont fichés
s mais qui sont sur situation de
résident non non non francophone, non
français, tu peux très bien procéder à
une vague d'expulsion et cetera et
cetera. Tant qu'ils ont pas commis de
délit, le pays le pays dont ils sont
partis peut pas les refuser. En général,
ils les refusent quand ils ont commis un
attentat parce qu'ils disent non,
celui-là vous le gardez.
Et en plus l'Europe nous dit vous pouvez
pas l'expulser parce que le pauvre il va
être torturé ou va être condamné à mort.
Donc si tu veux, il faut faire une
politique d'anticipation consistant à
vider le stock. Vider le stock, c'est en
particulier cette cible des étrangers en
situation de résidence légale ou
illégale mais qui sont qui sont
identifiés comme fichier S. La deuxième
chose, c'est effectivement taper à la
tête, c'est-à-dire taper sur
l'idéologie. Encore une fois, arriver à
dire que le salafisme a commencé à
attendre 2015 alors qu'il y avait déjà
eu MERA, Nemmouche et cetera. pour
commencer à parler du salafisme, c'est
qu'il y avait un retard à l'allumage des
politiques qui étaient quand même assez
dramatiques. Le troisème débat qui a été
complètement situé en porte à fou, c'est
le problème de la déchéance de
nationalité. La déchéance de
nationalité, le débat est tout de suite
parti sur le thème principe républicain
et cetera. Or, le droit du sol a été
inventé par Napoléon parce qu'il
manquait de troupe. Moi, j'ai jamais su
Napoléon était droit tout de gauche,
hein, mais enfin bon, je toujours est
utile que tout le monde s'est focalisé
en disant c'est un principe républicain,
ce qui est faux.
La deuxième chose, c'est que le type
disait "Mais vous savez, de toute façon,
ils s'en foutent puisque quand ils
arrivent en Syrie, ils brûlent leur
passeport. Comme tu le sais, si tu
détruis ton passeport, tu retournes au
consulat et tu dis "On me l'a volé, on
t'en refait un autre." Donc c'est pas un
geste d'une grande symbolique.
Moi ce qui me paraissait très important
dans le débat sur la déchance de
nationalité, c'est que comme je te le
disais, c'est le seul moyen de
démanteler ses cellules sur le
territoire. C'est-à-dire le problème,
c'est pas c'est une fois que le type est
mort, alors il dit là, il a plus besoin
de sa nationalité. C'est vrai, mais le
problème c'est le réseau, c'est-à-dire
que la déchance de nationalité était un
moyen justement d'appurer le passif du
réseau. Bon, donc ce débat été
particulièrement mal mené par mal mené
pas mal mené mais mal mené par Hollande
et Vals. On a refermé le dossier. Ça
paraît pourtant un problème extrêmement
grave encore une fois parce que
je te prends un exemple. Olivier Corel,
le type de la ferme d'Artigate a vu
passer tous les terroristes de 2015 et
2007 dans sa ferme. On n jamais réussi à
le coincer. On a jamais réussi à le
coincer. On l'a coincé parce qu'il avait
un fusil de chasse non déclaré. Mais
pourtant le degré de dangérosité de ce
type par rapport à ce qu'il a fait en en
2 ans et le les moyens légaux si tu veux
sont totalement disproportionnés.
Il y a peut-être une chambre d'aute.
Absolument. C'était peut-être à cause de
son activité de chambre d'ute. Mais je
te prends un autre exemple aussi qui est
très caractéristique notamment sur le
l'état d'urgence. Une des dispositions
de l'état d'urgence autorise la police à
faire ouvrir le coffre d'une voiture.
Comme tu vois, c'est la dictature
progresse à grand pas. L'attentat-ame,
les trois folles là, si tu veux, avait
déstocké des bonbonnes de gaz dans le
coffre de la voiture. Si on avait pas
été dans l'état d'urgence, le policier
aurait été obligé d'appeler une
fourrière qui aurait tracté la bagnole
pour l'amener dans une fourrière pour
ensuite sous l'autorité du juge,
arriver, ouvrir le coffre.
Comme tu vois, nous ne sommes pas en
situation de dangérosité absolue. Quand
on a légalisé cette situation, tu as
évidemment des gens qui t'ont expliqué
que la dictature progressé à grand pas
en France. D'ailleurs, c'est ce que
j'entends moi, à peu près une trentaine
d'années. Depuis tout petit, j'entends
que la dictature progresse en France.
Le secret des correspondances, quand on
y touche, ça touche le secret des
correspondances. Ah bah le secret des
correspondances si tu veux, je te dirais
franchement que je m'inquiète plus avec
le pouvoir des gafas qu'avec le pouvoir
de la police hein.
Parce que quand on voit effectivement
l'affaire
et le fait et le fait que ce que on
puisse violer le secret des
correspondances sans l'intervention d'un
juge.
Tu parles des dispositions
administratives introduites par l'état
d'urgence. Ouais, bien sûr. Il y a
toujours ces d'un juge, toujours, ne
serait-ce que après quand tu contestes.
Attends, attends. Oui. Oui. Parce que si
tu contestes la décision qui a violé ton
courrier, c'est le juge administratif
qui devient compétence. C'està-dire
qu'on a dessisi le juge judiciaire pour
confier au juge administratif.
Si je prends ton mot de passe de
téléphone portable lors de ta garde à
vue sans l'intervention d'un juge,
c'est pour ça que je m'inquiète beaucoup
plus des gafas que de que de la police
si tu veux.
Oui, parce que aujourd'hui je donne pas
si je ne donne pas mon code pin
lors d'une garde à vue, c'est 3 ans de
tôle de 170000 € d'amende si mes
souvenirs sont
1000000 ça fait un peu beaucoup quand
même. Mais encore une fois, on est dans
un système si tu veux dans lequel il y a
une justice. Donc que tu puisses refuser
ton ADN, que tu puisses refuser ton code
de pine, que tu et cetera et cetera. Je
veux dire dans une enquête judiciaire,
c'est une entrave à la marge de la
justice. Si tu as des choses à cacher,
c'est toi-même qui prend ton risque. Moi
je vois pas où est le problème. Je te
dis quand tu sais que tes données à toi
personnelles, elles peuvent basculer sur
Cambridge Analytica pour préparer une
élection,
une élection, je trouve que la violation
du de la vie privée est beaucoup plus
forte vis-à-vis d'acteurs privés qui
sont aujourd'hui les GAFA qu'elles ne
sont dans des États où tu as des
contrôles du juge. Tu qui contrôle
aujourd'hui les gafas ? personne qui il
faut faire attention parce qu'on est en
retard d'une guerre là aussi hein. On
est en retard d'une guerre
développe.
Je te dis moi la poursuite de
l'antiterrorisme
si tu sais que la logique de
l'antiterrorisme si tu veux c'est
d'anticiper l'acte terroriste et pas
d'attendre que le mec a fait sauter sa
bombe pour ensuite le poursuivre. Donc
on est dans une justice qui par nature
est une justice d'anticipation.
Bon, si tu sais que tu es dans une
situation ou dans une d'anticipation, il
faut que tu apportes suffisamment de
preuves pour expliquer au juges que tu
es en train d'écouter ce type là et
éventuellement tu vas le mettre en t
parce qu'il est en train de préparer
quelque chose qui va être un acte
terroriste, ce qui est tout à fait
différent de la criminalité habituelle.
Criminalité habituelle, tu attends qu'il
y a un acte criminel pour pouvoir le
poursuivre. Donc ça c'est la disposition
du droit français. Ce droit français, il
nous a permis d'éviter un certain nombre
d'attentats et je crois que l'année
dernière, il y en a une vingtaine ou une
trentaine qui ont été arrêtés en cours
de route. Donc
c'est bien sûr que c'est une justice
dérogatoire mais c'est une justice qui
s'adapte à la dangérosité du de la
menace terroriste. Donc je te dis moi
personnellement je sais que
moi régulièrement à t'apercevoir qu'on
t'a violé ton quand tes copains s'est
fait violer son mot de passe et que on
t'envoie un message de détresse.
Quand c'est encore ce genre de connerie,
ça va, tu t'en prémunis. Mais le jour où
on te détourne, le jour où des des
masses de données sont transférées, moi
je suis dans quelque chose pour lesquels
je trouve qu'il faudrait qu'on adapte
notre logiciel, hein.
Donc sacrifier tes libertés pour plus de
sécurité, ça te pose pas de problème.
Ça dépend quelle quelle liberté on
sacrifie.
Bon et concernant l'antiterroriste,
ils en ont pas un peu marre de faire les
femmes de ménage d'une politique
étrangère complètement schizophrénique ?
Oui, mais ça si tu veux, ça s'est
déclenché après le 11 septembre.
C'est-à-dire Bush nous a fait un coup
assez extraordinaire. Euh, il a
déclenché la Première Guerre mondiale
contre des concepts. Si tu veux, avant
c'était de la guerre contre des ennemis,
mais le jour où il décide la guerre
globale contre le terrorisme et la
prolifération,
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
de l'humanité qu'on fait la guerre à des
concepts. Le terrorisme, comme tu sais,
c'est un une forme de violence, c'est
pas un ennemi. Bon euh les résistants
français, ils s'étaient qualifiés de
terroristes par les Allemands et puis
nous, on a qualifié les féag français,
de terroristes et cetera. Donc encore
une fois, c'est une forme de violence.
Pourquoi je dis ça ? Parce que si tu
veux selon la forme du terrorisme, tu
peux le régler par des questions
politiques. Si s'il est palestinien
avent un état, il y a des chances que le
terrorisme baisse. Et puis il y a des
formes de violence notamment religieuses
si tu veux contre lesquelles il y a
aucun aucune modalité de négociation.
Donc tu peux pas mettre dans le même sac
comme l'a fait le département d'État les
40 ou 50 groupes terroristes qu'ils ont
listés tout à coup dans la guerre
globale contre le terrorisme. Deuxième
caractéristique, la guerre contre la
prolifération, c'est parfait. Ça dépend
ce qu'on appelle la prolifération. Donc
pour l'essentiel, on y mettait les armes
de destruction massive. Mais faut savoir
que pour les armes de destruction
massive ne serait-ce que la convention
chimique par exemple qui a été celle qui
a susciter si tu veux les réactions
antiassades.
Le congrès américain met deux limites à
l'application de la convention chimique
par les autorités américaines. Le
président a le droit de refuser une
inspection par défi. Tu sais que dans
les conventions internationales comme
ça, tu peux demander une inspection
surprise sur un pays signataire parce
que tu penses qu'effectivement il cache
des choses. Donc le président américain
a le pouvoir de refuser une inspection
par défi parce qu'on dit que c'est
parfois du secret industriel. Et
deuxième chose, il a le pouvoir
d'interdire que les échantillons
prélevés sortent des États-Unis. Donc le
même pays si tu veux qui explique que
Hassan ne respecte pas les trucs.
Troisème remarque mais enfin ça c'est
des mauvais souvenirs à pas rappeler.
Quand Saddam Hussein utilise les armes
chimiques, les précurseurs sont fournis
par les Américains et les Allemands. Bon
enfin ça c'est des souvenirs, c'est pas
grave. C'était avant qu'on ressigne la
convention chimique après l'utilisation
des armes chimiques à l'abja contre les
Kurdes dans lequel que la France a
refusé de condamner parce que on savait
pas soit la version officielle c'est
qu'on savait pas qu'il avait utilisé
l'arme chimique. Donc si tu veux, il y a
une histoire de focus et d'hypocrite qui
est assez remarquable. De la même façon
sur les autres sur les autres comment
dire disposition de la lutte
antiprolifération, les Américains ont
refugé de signer la convention sur
l'interdiction du décès d'armes
chimiques d'armes nucléaires pardon. De
la même façon, ils ont refusé
l'application de la Cour pénale
internationale proposée par Clinton mais
que le Congrès a refusé parce qu'ils
estiment que jamais un américain ne
devrait être jugé par une cour pénale
étrangère. Donc si tu veux, tu es dans
une situation où les donneurs de leçons
sont ceux qui devraient justement avoir
le plus de comment dire de rigueur
morale, mais ce n'est pas
automatiquement le cas. Voilà. Mais
c'est peut-être parce que je suis un
vieux cynique.
On arrive à la fin de notre interview.
On pose toujours la même question sur le
conseil pour les jeunes générations.
C'est une bouteille à la mer.
Le conseil pour les jeunes générations,
je sais pas, c'était le vieux slogan
indignez-vous. Indignez-vous parce que
c'est vrai qu'il faut le il faut garder
ça à l'esprit.
Euh mais il faut s'indigner sur tout.
Faut s'indigner sur tout ce qui mérite
qu'on s'indigne quoi. Le faut pas
mélanger la cause animale avec la surviv
de l'espèce humaine quoi. Par exemple,
il faut pas
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi ? Oh ben parce que
si tu veux, je l'autre fois j'étais à
Nice et je voyais euh un journal local
dans lequel on expliquait que une
réglementation qui oblige les
propriétaires de chiens à les tenir en
l'Est. Et tu vois, tu avais une
manifestation des propriétaires de
chiens pour les tenir en la qui
faisaient une page du NI matin. Bon,
j'ai trouvé que c'était une question
intéressante mais qui me paraissait pas
digne de se soulever l'indignation.
Tu tu connais la phrase qu'il y a dans
le manège de l'école de guerre ?
Non.
C'est on voit l'évolution alors de
souvenirs on voit l'évolution d'une
société à sa capacité à respecter ses
animaux.
Écoute, c'est une très belle phrase mais
qui est justement dans la dans le le
manège de l'école de guerre. Alors ce
manège de l'école de guerre, il y a 90
chevaux. Je sais parce que je me suis
occupé de la création du campus de
défense de l'école militaire. L'école
qui galope dans les gaz d'échappement.
Pardon ?
Qui galope dans les gaz d'échappement.
Attends parce que tu connais pas la fin
de l'histoire. Donc le campus l'école
militaire c'est 80000 m² dans le 7e
arrondissement. au prix du mètre carré
dans le 7e arrondissement, ça a une
certaine valeur. Dans cette école
militaire, tu as évidemment quelques
logements de fonction, le chef
d'étatmajor de marin des armées et
cetera plus un certain nombre d'écoles
militaires, l'école de guerre et cetera
et tu as aussi les voitures de Matignon.
Alors la vraie face c'est on reconnaît
le degré de civilisation d'un peuple la
manière dont il traite ses animaux
et tu as en particulier ce manège 90
chevaux qui est utilisé exclusivement
par les enfants du 7e arrondissement
parce que les militaires passent trop
peu de temps si tu veux sur le en poste
à Paris et comme il y a une très grande
il y a une très grande liste d'attente
bon
et donc dans l'utilisation de cet espace
qui est essentiel dans lequel moi je
proposais que puisse s'installer lesing
tank pour venir se mettre au contact des
militaires et travailler intelligemment
j'avais proposé le déplacement des des
90 chevaux
de l'école militaire. Je les avais
proposé de les mettre à Vincen puisque
il y a la garde républicaine là-bas et
donc ils auraient été à côté de de
l'autre cheptel. Bon alors j'ai eu des
réactions très étonnantes. Le le
capitaine qui dirige le cercle ipique
m'a expliqué qu'il lu fallait un bureau
de 40 m². Bon j'ai demandé s'il dormait
avec son cheval. Ensuite les mecs de la
gendarde républicaine ont dit "Mais
attendez, vous pouvez pas amener le vos
chevaux comme ça parce que s'ils sont
malades, ils vont affecter les notes."
J'ai dit "Mais il y a deux équipes
vétérinaires, c'est bien, on va pouvoir
en virer une des deux s'il y en a un des
deux qui affecte l'autre. Tu vois à peu
près le genre de truc, c'est une société
qui respecte plus ses animaux que ses
hommes et que son intelligence. Alors,
tu vois pourquoi je renverse la
perspective ? Quand tu es sur des
fromages comme cela, c'est-à-dire tu
peux respecter tes animaux en ayant une
intention intelligente de les utiliser
parce que quand les chevaux de l'école
militaire, on les sort enfin, on les
emène à Fontainebleau. Mais comme ces
pauvres chevaux, ils sont habitués à
tourner en rond dans le la grande cour
centrale de l'école militaire,
dès que tu les mets à la fontaine bleu,
il se trouvent tout à coup face à des
espaces et si c'est pas un bon cavalier,
le mec il se fait virer dans les 10
minutes parce que le cheval se met à
galoper, ce qui est sa fonction
naturelle. Et donc tu te retrouves dans
une situation où pour protéger les
enfants du 7e arrondissement et les
quelques endroits qui viennent tourner
autmières de persie des choses comme ça.
Et ben oui et ben tu te dis mais attends
je veux dire si tu veux respecter tes
animaux tu les mets dans un endroit où
ils peuvent galoper.
Tu penses quoi du végétarisme ?
Rien rien. Je suis désolé il y a des
sujets sur lesquels j'ai pas d'opinion.
Bon, allez, un conseil pour les jeunes
générations. Applique-toi. Ben,
je te dis, il faut s'indigner mais il
faut sélectionner. Il faut vraiment
prendre un champ de comment dire
d'indignation qui correspondent à la
réalité. Mais le problème c'est que
l'accès au médias, si tu veux
aujourd'hui euh est une espèce de
comment dire de mécanisme qui comment
dire qui suscite tellement de
de d'envie et de jalousie que tu arrives
à avoir des gens qui défendent des
causes particulièrement surprenantes.
Par exemple, une fois je voyais une
interview d'une présidente d'une
association de défense des rotweilers.
Je me disais si elle il y a une défense
des Rotweiler, elle expliquait que
c'était des chiens extrêmement gentils
et qu'il en avait tort de les
diaboliser. Bon, il venait de bouffer un
gosse quelques mois plus tôt. Donc
c'est qu'il y a plus de morsure de
labrador et de tquel que de roteller et
de monosoïdes sur les Yamins.
D'où l'utilité de les tenir en la
tu vois ? Ben non, les animaux, je veux
dire quand ils sont la parce que tout
animal par moment, il peut avoir un coup
de tout cou et puis effectivement mordre
un enfant, mordre. Mais si tu veux, on a
renversé l'ordre des facteurs en disant
"Mais attention les pauvres animaux, il
faut les traiter comme nous." Non, non,
c'est faux. Je suis désolé, je suis un
vieux réac sur le sujet mais je pense
que si tu veux, il y a des choses que
il y a des choses qui sont très
étonnantes. Tu jamais aux États-Unis, tu
aurais ce débat. Les mecs qui disent il
y a une roi qui est interdit qui oblige
les gens des propriétaires de chiens à
les tenir en laisse, bon ben on met une
la c'est tout. Tandis qu'en France, on
explique que c'est une violation des des
droits constitutionnels. Donc non, je
suis pas
C'est tout.
Bah oui, c'est tout. On peut arrêter là.
J'en ai suffisamment détré. Pierre
connaî ça. Merci. De rien. Merci à toi.
couper
[Musique]